so you can
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
perfect
[Music]
yo what's up guys sorry we uh had a
pre-podcast demonetization discussion
that should not be aired yeah it was bad
it was pretty bad what's up i'm thomas
dopesy whatever you want to call me this
is marty o'neal jurassic graphics what's
up folks what's up what's up it's 11 of
the morning we're drinking beers yes sir
fun times all right we're getting it
going guys uh this is the dope usual
podcast we're here to talk about life
problems drugs accomplishments and
everything in between and today is a lot
of
everything in between hinting a little
bit on the [ __ ] drugs accomplishments
and some fails and it's gonna be fun
guys this is i don't know what episode
now but goblin goblin's back you guys
ask every five seconds
so three
no this might be four including the eric
one this is your third time you've been
on the show third third like just me you
yeah i think
is this correct
okay yeah 10 hours of of us talking
about stuff wow that's a lot of content
that is a lot of content i'm going to
drop a like for that for real that's
10 hours
yeah how about that 1.3 million or
whatever on that [ __ ]
the goat episode yeah doing crazy yeah
that pop back up i recommended the other
day imagine if that wasn't age
restricted yours got age restricted at
like 600. dude if none of them got age
restricted it would be filling up
right now
i think about it all the time like yo
what kind of house would i have i never
got
because youtube owes me 2.9 million
dollars youtube that i've never gotten
from my page
well let's start off on a better note
let's start off let's talk about
something fun
yeah depressed me yeah no that hurt me
that hurt me let's get on to something
that won't get us demonetized yeah i was
going to say how are we going to sit
here do 10 minutes what is the pressing
start it's okay no demonetized let's
talk about acid
all right let's start by adding two
minutes into it barney's already rolling
this episode is done like you know
yeah let's just talk about whatever we
want okay here we go you ready yeah i am
going to ask you some things and let's
hear that you let me know okay all right
i'm just gonna throw out some key words
getting lost
three tabs of acid
you
i'm looking at your youtube and that's
the title and i go oh no is that when i
was in the forest
i have no you tell me i have no idea
i've gotten lost on acid many times
that's the thing there was trees in the
thumbnail
i'm pretty sure that was when i was in
the forest preserve
but the thing is i've also gotten lost
trying to walk home from my friend's
house on acid even though he lived
literally across the street
because that was one of my earlier trips
but then it happened again on a later
trip
i actually recently i'm on a bit of a
hiatus from acid right now because uh i
i tripped back in like march and i had a
bad trip oh recent yeah like this is
like at home no i was in i was in a
hotel with emily we were in chicago and
um
we were we we took like so i'd gotten
new tabs right i know this totally isn't
once you asked but we'll get to that
yeah um
so i got these tabs right
oh that was a good crack
that one's sprayed
that was bad no that that was good
honestly that's a good good one um no
but so i we i got these new tabs and i'd
never gotten them from this person
before right um and they were advertised
as double dose but like everyone says
that so i don't take it seriously and
that's where i [ __ ] up um
so we they were they were supposedly 175
ug each what's a single dose
around like a hundred eugee what's that
mean ug um i don't know what the ug
actually stands for like the scientific
thing mg
less than mg yes yeah a milligram of
acid you'd be tweaking for like days
that's that's so much acid like a
milligram is sort of like a gram
dude i am so happy i asked this because
if i took ass i would have took a gram
no you can't take like a gram though
like the way it's dosed out you take a
tab of it and each of the tabs have like
you know 100 150 ug sometimes a little
less sometimes a little more um dude you
know
there's a so there was this i i've
watched a video about this there's this
like bunker that back in the 70s these
dudes were like cooking a bunch of acid
in and the feds raided it and like
hazmat suits and one of their suits got
punctured and the guy took i don't
remember the amount the equivalent of
like 70 000 hits of acid or something
and he was in the hospital for like ages
like tweaking out like they couldn't get
him to come down and he survived
like he's like still i don't know if
he's still alive but live he survived
yeah dude i couldn't imagine the impact
of that because like
just the impact of one like a small dose
bad trip is already bad enough but
imagine 70 000 heads
that'd be [ __ ] sad holy [ __ ] dude and
on accident too
like the thing with acid is like you got
to prepare for it you know you got to
like be ready to trip imagine having
never done that drug before and your
first dose is more than anyone in
history has ever done
and you're a square yeah and you're like
some sober you're a fed you're literally
a federal agent like you're you're the
king of you're jake jake johnson like
would suck yeah
is it a roll the dice every time with
the bad trip or not necessarily i mean
there's there's things you can do to
like prep to have a better trip um and
it's kind of all about knowing your
limits because i mean no matter how good
of a time you're having if you take too
much it's gonna get bad you know
um do you feel like in your mind like
like is there ever a moment where you're
sitting there and you're like up
starting to feel go a little sideways if
i start thinking i'm like that's with
every joke yeah so that's actually what
happened with my last trip um
so like i said i'd gotten these tabs
from someone that i'd never gotten them
for uh from before right so they were
advertised double dose i didn't listen
to it we're chilling in the hotel we had
planned in advance like two trip one of
the days we were together um just
because it was like super nice out the
whole week it was just getting warm
again in chicago um so we wanted to like
trip halls and do something fun you know
so we started off we only took like
what half a tab to start
yeah like half a tab wait emily you do
you ask it too
yeah we yeah we took it together yeah
your face lit yeah
i love it
um
so
we uh we started with like half a tab
and we we like came up and we're feeling
okay but we weren't tripping very hard
you know so you're like okay so explain
that though what is the internal feeling
because mushrooms i feel like
a sponge
no no
personally i get a really like euphoric
kind of feeling where i almost feel like
warm the way i always describe it is
it's like my veins are like full of hot
chocolate you know like i just feel warm
like i just feel fuzzy i feel fun
feeling i feel really good and i feel
light almost like i'm getting lifted up
and you start looking around you and you
start noticing that colors are more
vibrant and some things have patterns
that didn't have patterns over them
before like things that are normally
stable start to look like a gif you know
like things are moving like
if you've ever taken acid you appreciate
a cool ceiling
because like you'll sit in a room like
if i was tripping right now i'd stare at
your [ __ ] ceiling for like two hours
probably you know because of all the
different patterns and like things
moving on it so like we started to come
up and we had some light visuals we're
like you know colors were more vibrant
and you know i internally i was feeling
really good and i i was having a great
trip at first so i was like yo we should
take some more so
maybe like i don't know two or three
hours in i don't exactly remember it
might not even have even been that long
we took another tab like just a full tab
each so yeah
so now we're at one and a half tabs and
the advertised dose of these was a 175
ugs so that's about like
250 275 ug which is a you know a decent
dose but like i've done more than that
before i know lots of people have done
more than i ever have before so like
that's a pretty normal dose for me still
um
so after we took that extra tab
where i made the mistake is i took a fat
ass dab
and when you're tripping weed doesn't
hit you like it does on any other drug
like on shrooms i don't know if i've
ever really
smoked heavy so like i don't like i can
smoke a gram and be fine does it make
you like feel better though
do you just kind of not feel it i don't
feel [ __ ] on mushrooms really
that's interesting on acid power smoke
it's almost like the opposite so like it
makes you trip harder like really
intense like really crazy
um
and after we we took a couple dabs we i
dropped like a smaller one and then i
had this container with like maybe a
point three left in it oh it's clean and
yeah i just scraped out the whole thing
and dropped it um because i wasn't the
ritos hadn't hit me yet i wasn't
tripping very hard so i was like oh hell
yeah dude i can i can drop a fat dab
right now
and i think the timing's also where i
[ __ ] up because what happened was
i started feeling the redos that second
like that extra tab i took at the same
time as the dab was making me start to
like come up
so it felt like i was just on like this
rocket ship almost and i had this
feeling that like you know the whole
like hot chocolatey feeling i was
talking about wasn't like exciting
anymore it was like too much like i was
getting overwhelmed so i remember
we were laying in bed and i just started
tweaking out i got up and i like walked
over to the bathroom and i was just like
bro how do i feel like this and i
started freaking out because as i was
looking around my visuals were getting
like way more intense than i'd ever had
like i don't think i've ever had acid
visuals this crazy and i've done doses
like double this amount
so
more than that so
when the visuals started getting crazy
you know those like what are they
kaleidoscopes those little things you
look through and you see like six of
everything or like you know that's what
everything looked like to me like i
couldn't process my surroundings anymore
so i kept having to kind of like tell
myself like
oh [ __ ] you know i'm like
kept kind of repeating like where i was
to keep myself grounded like okay i'm in
the hotel room you know it's it's me and
emily here uh we're chilling you know
like nothing bad is happening but no
matter how much i did that and told
myself that
it it didn't do anything like my visuals
were more intense than anything i'd ever
experienced and i was freaking the [ __ ]
out
so
shout out miller light um so
um so i i went through this you know
emily and i we went through this
probably like two or three hour period
of just like
freaking the [ __ ] out like we tried to
lay in bed but it was really
overwhelming
and the only thing that carried me
through this trip was playing elden ring
on my playstation distracting your head
dude i don't know why because like
everything else around wait you're at a
hotel with video games i brought my
playstation
yeah that's how you're talking oh yeah
and you know originally i know i got a
lot of comments at least when i made a
video about this saying like i should
have gone outside and everything and
normally that would work like going
outside it's really nice when you're
tripping um
but we're in a hotel in downtown chicago
so if we go outside we're just
surrounded by people and like the worst
thing ever when you're tripping at least
for me is being in a crowded place i
hate it like i can't do it like i've
gone to restaurants while i'm tripping
you know i've gone to like public places
before while i'm tripping but
when you're having a bad time like being
surrounded is so overwhelming like i
wanna i wanna be alone yeah dude um so
ten minutes it's been ten minutes it's
been ten minutes oh let's get started oh
yeah
oh yeah it's a stone [ __ ] sure it's a
hat oh thank you you have a lighter do i
yeah i do yeah
do you have one
um
it's the worst
having a bad trip is the worst so
i um
you've still never done acid right i
remember you you'd honestly have no
desire it's cool but like if you don't
want you don't force yourself to you
have to really want it you know
mushrooms and they grow in the ground
i get that the whole natural the feel of
it acid i i've heard
million positive stories i've heard like
three bad ones and those three bad ones
scare me enough to go
the bad ones are horrible i don't i
can't i don't think i could ever quite
explain the feeling of like
terror that i felt during that not even
the bad trip the repercussions of what
it does to some people's sights psyche
mental stuff yes
yes it literally drives people crazy
i've seen one person they're complete
schizophrenic now yeah they ran in their
family yeah
either is it the asset or was it just
destined i knew a kid in high school
used to take a lot of acid and he got
locked up in a mental ward for like six
months yeah you were telling me like he
went [ __ ] nuts another what was it i
think
was it earl sweatshirt this earl
sweatshirt i can't remember one of his
songs he talks about taking bad acid now
he's [ __ ] up
see i i don't really listen to earl
sweatshirts
do you make good music yeah
it's good music for people that don't
want to listen to [ __ ] melodies and
crazy it's just this [ __ ] you
know who earl sweatshirt is not really
no he's [ __ ] hard anyway um
bad trip sorry can continue you said you
didn't want to go in to the crowd of
chicago yeah i didn't want to go outside
to go in public but our room had a
balcony but emily was having a really
bad trip and she didn't like though
at the same time yeah
maybe it's the acid guys it had to be
right it's not just a dab you took a fat
dab
we took a fat dab that was the acid then
it was kind of both it was chicken
two yeah we both we both hit it we both
hit it yeah um and we both took the same
size burritos so we were both having
just as bad of a time as each other um
it was really overwhelming because it's
not like one could trips hit the other
like it's not like either of us were
having a good time we were both having
an awful experience so
i remember i wanted to go out to the
balcony but she like for some reason
just like in her head was like freaking
out about the balcony she was like oh
don't go out there you know like don't
don't go on the balcony like thinking
something bad was gonna happen which
happens a lot with acid you know you
have a bad trip you get in a thought
loop you're kind of [ __ ] uh and you're
gonna think that way for a while until
you come out of it so i remember we we
eventually since you know we couldn't
leave the room couldn't go on the
balcony couldn't do much
we laid in bed and i just played [ __ ]
elden ring
and i don't know what it was bro i
unlocked this like inner like gamer dude
like everything else around me like i
[ __ ] you not
i was tripping so hard visually that i
couldn't recognize basic things around
me like if someone asked me what that
lamp was you know like the lamp on my
nightstand i couldn't tell you it was a
[ __ ] lamp it's like blurred out not
necessarily blurred out but just so much
was happening on and around the lamp it
didn't look like a lamp to me anymore
and you know
it's almost like there was a disconnect
from what i was seeing to what my brain
was getting out of it you know like
i i would see something but my brain
wouldn't process that that's what i was
seeing i'd just be like oh that looks
cool you know look at the pattern it
wouldn't be like that's a lamp you know
it was like almost something in my brain
got severed you know
yeah so
i would think it would be hard to lock
onto a video game see that's the thing
sometimes i find at least i i'm like
games really hold it down for me when
i'm tripping like
for some reason when i looked at the
screen i understood what was happening
still and i almost felt this like inner
feeling where it was like
it's almost like the game represented
like the bad trip to me like i had to
kill the boss to get out of the bad trip
so i started playing the game i killed i
[ __ ] you not i like doubled my progress
in the game in the span of like three
hours bro like i killed like six bosses
in like three hours and normally
like that game is really hard bro it'll
take me like three hours to kill one or
two dudes you know and
i'm sitting there and i'm fighting this
really hard boss
and i'm playing the game for so long and
i'm sitting there like dude if i kill
this boss like i'll get out of the trip
like this is the this is my i'm fighting
my inner demons right now like literally
like it didn't even feel like a video
game at that point um
and it was weird too because i remember
at one point i took a break from it
and i was having like i was starting to
kind of come out of the bad trip as i
played the game more and then as soon as
i closed the game and tried to play a
different one i bought the jumanji video
game because i was like that'd be fun
while i'm tripping
i couldn't even understand the screen i
couldn't even read the text like it's
like i started having a bad trip again i
went immediately back down i was like
dude i gotta get back on alden ring you
know like how long does this last
i'd say probably like four or five hours
sounds terrible yeah it wasn't the whole
trip once we started coming down and
like you know we passed our peak then it
was actually a decent trip see this is
doesn't make me want to do acid
i don't blame you as a fat no i'm saying
that's a fat joke i'm over here yeah
yeah you know i'm not here oh [ __ ] i'm
i'm out here
marty can you tell marty rolls blunts
first i was just thinking that i'm like
i roll these [ __ ]
and then moved over and rolled the other
half like a [ __ ] swisher so yeah i
only roll blood so i can't roll joints
for [ __ ] i will teach you in five
seconds you will have it down like
nothing if you don't want him super fat
i can roll him by uh no no eyes if you
want him skinny i can make him look like
needles really he hangs upside down
like you could do so much more rolling a
joint you know for sure blunts are
construction yeah yeah but no on that
bad trip i remember
once we started uh kind of coming down
and feeling better a little bit we
ordered some pizza have you ever had
chicago style pizza [ __ ] in your life
crazy is it for sauces on top yes oh
[ __ ] with that [ __ ] don't ever say that
[ __ ] when you're in the same room as me
why is it that good i hate it
it's the
single finest style of pizza i know
there's going to be a ton of pissed off
new yorkers in the comments and that's
fine there's a lot of shitty chicago
style there is but when you find a good
example of it yeah i don't know if i've
ever had a pizza almost not pizza
because you got to eat it with a fork
and a knife because to me it's more like
you i made this it's almost like a
lasagna crust you know i'm saying like
you made a bomb sandwich you know what
let me drown that [ __ ] in mustard or
something
let me cover what i just saw
and so you can't see what the [ __ ] is
under it like yo what the [ __ ] is this
about trust dude this sauce just holds
cheese i worked at a pizza like a
five-star pizza place for five years
i i'm really good at making pizzas and
[ __ ] i've done the sauce on top i'm just
not a fan i think it's what i get i'm
just not a [ __ ] fan it's very heavy
and there's no
all dogs go to heaven cheese pool or
there's nothing oh no
you're not getting deep dishes i'm like
that too yeah it's thick right yeah oh
there's no
that's nice
you had la version of chicago that's why
that's why that's why that's why if you
ever get a chance to go to chicago
don't ever say that in my presence this
is [ __ ]
i'm advocating for this [ __ ] i only had
the losses so good
it's so good i don't eat cheese so my
version suck dick true yeah vegan pizza
[ __ ] sucks dick does it it's the
worst dude i remember that vegan place
you put me onto last time i was here was
fire fire that that was like a few vegan
places that have good pizza
i mean my friend owns
the best one i don't know dude those
burgers slap that [ __ ] oh which place
you talking about man i don't know what
was it called i don't remember the name
is it plant power was it it might have
been vegan junk it was like the the
knockoff big mac black power
the big zach
i love the name of that thing dude yeah
big zack
sorry yo this is rant city for all of us
you ordered pizza
chicago pizza uh-huh as you're as you're
tripping
yes that's how we got to this point yes
so i i almost forgot about that honestly
holy [ __ ] i was just ripping the joint
okay so yeah we ordered some pizza and
we went downstairs as we were having a
better trip and like we were able to
start like our visuals were coming down
we were able to kind of like comprehend
our surroundings again um so we went
downstairs and we got our pizza and i
just remember in the elevator this
[ __ ] guy gets in and like i'm still
tripping pretty hard my eyeballs are
like
my peoples are bowling balls at this
point
and this guy i'm just like staring at
him the whole time cause like i don't
know bro i couldn't stop looking at him
like i was just tripping so hard i felt
bad because now that i look back i'm
like dude this guy's been like horrified
bro like you must have thought i was
about to stab him dude the [ __ ]
genuine my eyes are just like my pupils
are just all black dude you can't even
see the color in my eye and i'm just
glaring at this man for like thought
he's going up like probably like 12
floors or some [ __ ] and i'm just mugging
him the whole time i just saw a t-shirt
when you described that just wholesome
looking goblin blacked out eyes duster
yeah he was looking away he was looking
at me so funny oh i definitely was
sweating and he's staring at back at you
yeah dude because like i wouldn't stop
looking at him he was on acid no no he's
telling a story in his podcast
there was this really awesome guy i was
just i feel bad but we got our pizza and
went upstairs and then like i started
coming down and the pizza clutched up
honestly the pizza clutched up that
should save the trip by the time that
all happened it was probably like
i don't know maybe 1 a.m at this point
12 30. uh and we'd initially like this
all started when we took that first half
tab at like maybe 4 p.m
so this had been like already an eight
hour deal i didn't end up actually being
able to fall asleep
until 9am the next day yeah so this this
was over 12 hours that this all went
down yeah because like i i don't know
what it is i mean normally
it's difficult to fall asleep after you
trip always always but it's it's never
been that hard for me and i just think
it's because i had such a [ __ ] time you
know like
i had this weird like
this weird feeling because emily fell
asleep way before me she felt like like
5am so i was sitting there on my phone
scrolling through like tick tock and
[ __ ] trying to find dumb [ __ ] to well i
watch these guys like um like reviewing
boats like they're like touring boats i
watched them for like two hours that
sounds so boring no it was cool bro they
like these speed boats and [ __ ] they're
like yachts like yo dude check out this
yacht it's got a [ __ ] sick ass like
chandelier and like it's kind of oh a
tour of the boat yeah a tour of the boat
yeah okay i watched that with houses
yeah yeah it's like houses but like a
boat so yeah it's cool like oh this one
has a helipad on it like what the [ __ ]
like who this guy sells cocaine yeah
like who's landing their helicopter on
there like what
you know the
all right can we just land a helicopter
in a boat one day
docked because i ain't going in the
water that'd be so sick what's wrong
with going on the water oh [ __ ] with the
water really
nope why why's that it's like walking
into a room blindfolded i mean you don't
know who someone's ready to stab you and
or bite you
all right here ready this is how i
always compare it people like the ocean
statistically you're less likely to
[ __ ] die
in a plane crash or something [ __ ]
stupid then get bit by a shark right
people say it all the time yep
but there's a chance
there is if i tell you yo yo we're gonna
go to a baseball game
there also is a chance there might be a
lion running around
i mean you're not wrong
no i'm never going to do the park again
no it's more like a lion there's
definitely lions but you might not you
might not get them yeah you probably
won't see one
they're probably busy they're invisible
because in the water you don't see a
shark
you're on a big-ass boat what's up
what's a shark gonna do
boat sink
dude you're on a yacht you think a shark
is gonna sink your yacht you're talking
to ben stiller from a long time paulie
here i've never seen that movie fully so
i don't know i mean you talk about like
you've seen the megalodon movies and
[ __ ] like the big ass
you ever seen those movies about
megalodon
please tell me someone had it marty yeah
she just smoked that [ __ ] can yeah i
didn't even notice okay all right
wait what did he do
i thought i was [ __ ] up for a second
okay i wanted the people watching going
what am i tripping but he didn't notice
so at least some of you guys i didn't
know he's not even noticed i'm gonna
have to watch this when it comes out i
just pretended to smoke this can it
happens
like legitimately i accidentally always
do this all that when i'm like [ __ ]
smoking a joint it's so dumb
so you're telling me
if you're on a yacht there's no chance
of it going down have you ever heard of
boats not because of a [ __ ] no not
because of a shark because what happens
if you get in the water they live there
yeah but like bro you got to be bleeding
for them to come up and get that's
that's your statement
it's so rare it's so rare seals don't
have blood so rare for that to occur
though okay it's true but it's also rare
to get eaten by a [ __ ] tiger but do
you want to go
oh the statistics of this as you're
[ __ ] hitting something yeah i mean
statistically this shouldn't be
happening doesn't matter
sure
but
i i it's like this yo wear a red shirt
you're obviously so shocked your hands
have to be so unbelievably bad because
not only do you have my block sucks just
think about this not only do you have to
have the very low chance of your yacht
sinking somehow but then the very low
chance of you getting eaten by something
after the yacht sinks well the water is
trying to kill you itself that's the
other vehicle yeah the grass at the park
doesn't drown
oh
if you fall off your atv at the park
the ground's hot lava if you if you
compare it to the ocean like oh i could
die in there yeah okay
the park isn't going to drown you you're
right the grass isn't going to drown out
i'd rather stay on
the water's so sick i'll stare at it
i'll be like that
that should sing go smoke weed out there
you can go fishing i don't like fish and
i don't like what's wrong with what i
don't hurt no fish you don't have to
hurt them just catch them with their own
bag bro you [ __ ] hook them through
the face that's their problem
i just came into their house and went
here's some [ __ ] i let him live yeah
i mean it's like this is like a walk
into my kitchen i go damn who made me a
sandwich oh [ __ ] i bought it
i remember you're in my house what the
[ __ ] that's how i think of it when i was
a kid i remember i uh i came to vacation
out here one time and i went on this
little fishing boat
um and
it was like they had this like
quote unquote chef it was just some dude
in an apron
and he'd butcher your fish for you
on the boat so like people would just a
[ __ ] homeless man yeah
dude no he was not no chef he was just
some random like really scuffed like
greasy guy who would butcher your fish
for you and and cook it so
people would catch some [ __ ] on the boat
yes they had they had a [ __ ] stove
inside it was like this little fishing
boat and they had a little kitchen in
there
and like this dude would put the fish on
a table and just [ __ ] kill it and
throw their heads back in
yeah so [ __ ] sad yeah continue well i
don't know if you're throwing back i
don't know what he did with the heads to
be fair but yeah no he's thinking james
he like he like got them he'd like take
the bones out and then like cook it
like for you like if you caught
something edible right that's crazy yeah
i was like 12 years old and i remember i
caught some [ __ ] but i threw it back
because i didn't want to eat it you know
i was like i don't know
my grandpa took me fishy in snelling by
merced when i was like six and then i
had to hook a worm it's the only time i
ever [ __ ] went fishing in my life i
hooked one worm and i felt so [ __ ]
terrible
thinking like you're just dying waiting
to get eaten
yeah this is horrible i don't want to
fish anymore and then i started using
the bait with the lid and he's drowning
yes
the worm is gruesome
he's drowning and he's about to get
eaten
and they don't hurt whether you catch
something or not he's gonna get eaten
he's dead yeah so sad but it's just like
i was eating meat like that when i was a
kid
that's when i realized i don't like it
when you think about it it's just kind
of natural selection though like it'd
just be that way
that's it i mean that's
what man has always said yeah we
i mean always throughout history we've
been doing that [ __ ] you know i mean i
mean in a way we kind of are the apex
predator you know like we that's not
true
not i mean yeah certain animals will
kill us but we have guns and [ __ ] right
i'm saying if we just did this like
we're like seventh
yeah
[Applause]
we have semi trucks bro we have the
luxury to feel bad about them now yeah
we do
we grinded for this yeah we grinded for
this we [ __ ] grinded through the
medieval times we grinded to be able to
kill fish
hey what's up guys taking a minute to
talk about one of our longtime sponsors
and this is manscaped right now if you
go to
www.manscape.com forward slash yola you
get 20 off your entire order plus free
shipping quick announcement for
manscaped the ultra smooth package is
finally back the ultra smooth package
it's in the name it's to keep your balls
smooth and not gross so this is what
comes in the ultra smooth package guys
it's back on manscape.com take advantage
of it while it's here you guys already
know that's what we talk about all the
time it is the shaver this is the
thing that you're going to put real
close to your dick so you want it to be
really [ __ ] well made from personal
use from me to you it is very well made
the second thing in the ultra smooth
package is the crop exfoliator guys this
is to make sure well it helps with
ingrown hair soothing and all that the
third thing is the crop gel this has
essential oils and this is
this is like the care products it's so
funny because it's all for your digging
balls but this is the spa treatment for
your dick the last thing in the ultra
smooth package is the crop shaver this
has the pivoting head this is the shaver
this is for the up close and personal
ball shaving once again thank you so
much to manscape for sponsoring the
podcast it's always fun to do these ad
reads before you get out of you remember
manscape.com forward slash yolo is 20
off your whole order plus free shipping
guys thank you so much for supporting
the brands that support us back to this
goblin episode
what the [ __ ] were we talking about
how did we get onto the ocean boats
a helicopter you mentioned you were
scared of the ocean oh yeah i'm [ __ ]
with that [ __ ] also some parts you know
what might have demons we've never seen
you know what i'm scared just like the
ocean like yo we haven't been down there
i'm scared of heights same here you know
why because you'll [ __ ] die from them
yes yeah there's nothing to do there's
nothing at the bottom will save you you
fall in the water you're still dead it
doesn't you'll pass out and drown
doesn't matter
like i don't [ __ ] with heights bugs or
open water what about bugs scares you no
i just don't like bugs crawling on me
okay oh yeah of course no it's horrible
that's horrible spiders scare the [ __ ]
out of me i can't do spiders that's kind
of what i'm talking spiders are like
actually scary other bugs
i'll kill them but spiders like i get
genuinely like i like killing bugs so i
have to trap all these
[ __ ] what are you trapping with
a cup and a newspaper and i go oh school
we had a scorpion in our bed in texas
one time yes that's when we're going to
move to texas you have scorpions inside
your house you had a [ __ ] scorpion a
wild scorpion they have good housing
prices dude i had a um i had a like a i
don't know if it was a possum or what
was something moved up when i pulled it
[ __ ]
and it was like going into my garbage
bins and like oh i was [ __ ] [ __ ] up
yeah outside you said
it no no it didn't no
that [ __ ]
or a groundhog or what the [ __ ] it was
but something went under my porch
um
and i i went to walmart i couldn't get
it out i like
i i tried to call like services and
they're like yeah we don't do that [ __ ]
we do like bugs and [ __ ] yeah we don't
do that [ __ ] like we
we're not gonna do that [ __ ] and i was
just like you know what i'm just gonna
go to walmart and get one of those
little bb guns one of those little red
rider guns and do what i gotta do so do
whatever
just annoy it to death
well there's a i could see the entrance
that it does under my porch so one day i
remember i just stuck the barrel under
there and just
but nothing was in there
so i thought the story was gonna be
crazy as hell no i thought i went bow
bow bow
came out and choked this [ __ ] out no it
was one of those little like lever like
tiny you know christmas story
not quite a bow bow but you know either
way there's some
you could [ __ ] pass them up with one
of those yeah that's awesome
that's just like 20 bucks you know like
they're so cheap i mean a red rider
yeah i mean when you you rather one had
pellets you guys have a pellet gun not a
bb gun the pellet gun that had like the
little diamond
bb's oh god that's all no those going on
your skin you never had pellets
they're like diamond shaped like bullets
see i used to i used to play a lot of
paintball you have to do paintball i
just did it recently paintball's fun bro
so [ __ ] fun paintball's a blast i
like it way better than airsoft and all
that [ __ ] i never did airsoft but
paintball is [ __ ] fun when i was a
kid at airsoft was popular but like more
in the sense that like you just like go
to the park and some kid would just
shoot you you know
but it doesn't leave a big ass welt
though right oh yeah yeah air software
it depends on the kind of gun you have
what is airsoft shooting at you are a
little plastic bb's
the gun shoot at different speeds
okay like they have different power to
them so like if you have one that's like
a rifle you'll really do more damage
than someone oh i'm kidding i'm kidding
i've seen somebody go into their skin
embedded and then pull it out you get
hit in the eye you're [ __ ] yeah
[ __ ] like that you gotta wear goggles
they're serious but like i remember like
kids when i was in middle school and she
used to just like have airsoft guns it
was like fun it's like we go hang out
and just like you know shoot each other
and park and [ __ ] it's terrible i mean
like like everybody doing at the same
time yeah i mean that was amazing i mean
sometimes if you know if you were
lacking i thought you just meant
no sometimes i mean if you if you didn't
have it already you just shot the best i
know people be like you know so some
friends would be like oh like let's you
know let's go to the park and like that
obviously implied we're bringing
yourself guns you know so
what neighborhood were you when you guys
could just roll around with fake guns oh
a nice neighborhood i didn't grow up in
a bad area wow nice neighborhood
suburban suburban chicago
very different
how how how are you guys shooting each
other in public and not getting shot
well it was just it was the park of our
like i get it now it was a part of our
our elementary school back in the day
and like no one would be there on
weekends that's amazing so we just go
there and there's a huge field behind
like right behind it so like there's so
much room to do [ __ ] so we just [ __ ]
around
oh man that sounds [ __ ] sick you ever
shoot roman candles at each other no i'm
not those are fun [ __ ]
those hurt you'll get a real burn
you've done that yeah you get like a
direct hit like you've done that for
real
i had i had to run in with some ramen
candles once this food could have said
yep throwing pop rocks at people is fun
too that's a more casual thing see
throwing pop rocks you know those little
oh you mean the poppers poppers yeah
throwing those are people are still fun
yeah oh man that's what i just threw
some pop rocks out of four once it went
in his eye
oh
he was going down the stairs i was on
the top of the stairs and i just flung
him there
right in his eyes
marty was amazed i blinded the kid in
sixth grade didn't even mean to do it
yeah you did no
it wasn't a [ __ ] accident but yeah he
meant to hit him though i didn't think
it was going to go in his eye i was fine
i did it
probably going for like a chat shot what
time are we at
40 40.
yeah um
i'm pretty sure let's uh bust into some
edibles [ __ ] yeah and then maybe we'll
light another joint and i have a
question for you awesome let's do it
okay so these we're gonna start with the
sharks
the sharks
all right i've tried these i think i
don't know which ones you tried oh
i believe i've tried these
that's a big shark
that's such a big shark
oh i got a siamese one
do it hold on oh [ __ ]
all right
marty
uh yeah i'll take a punch i'm a kimbo
right now i got
a kimbo yeah two
what did that mean
like in call of duty when you have two
guns you gotta kimbo pistols i have no
[ __ ] idea
so
we'll see how these work
i like
everybody's just chewing sorry guys
sorry for everybody driving going oh
this is disgusting these [ __ ] sharks
are amazing not even that like i'm sorry
for just
all three of us
could you imagine what it sounds like on
the road yeah someone in the car is
going somebody in the car just stopped
it's like a jump scare and somebody went
is this for watching porn
[Laughter]
i'm sorry
well here's some sharks if you want some
more sharks eat these [ __ ]
let me finish this guy
shout out to shark
here we go
question
you
have you talked about this
on anywhere yet well you probably have
you have a podcast you're about to start
doing
all right you guys are ready
are you guys ready sorry i have so many
sharks in my teeth hold on
you know maybe i won't be eating uh
we'll eat them at separate times that
way we're all not just silent
we just did 20
we did talk about sharks i know i'm
scared of those but not these
i mean this helps get over your fear
we're like
asserting dominance over charlotte on
land yeah exactly
how ironic yeah sharks wouldn't make it
here
sharks would make it here they can't do
taxes
exactly they can't they can't even walk
bro they can't even walk where they're
gonna buy shoes they can't wear a mask
do you think anyone's gonna push a shark
around in a wheelchair how's he gonna
get around he has no hands you can't use
the electric ones he can't steer he
doesn't have [ __ ] help he can't do
[ __ ] anything he's gonna be homeless
but he's gonna die they can't even read
no they can't read or speak english
[ __ ] thank you they can't even speak
english
that's true but people still get through
life we're not speaking english yeah but
like you know some of these they don't
speak any language
we just don't understand their language
it's too good for us that's yeah you're
right but that's the problem no one's
gonna start speaking shark if they move
here
so like remember when we just started
talking about this anybody remember this
i do i do this is usually like about two
and a half hours into this [ __ ] yeah i
don't know also when we were looking
down i just looked down yeah it never
looked straight down i could see the
bottom of this beer can it's wild
it's so yellow oh that's cool
look at the back lighting
yeah the lighting in here is insane
sorry sorry for everyone driving let's
get back on [ __ ] track
are you ready you have a podcast coming
out sir and uh what's gonna happen and
uh where's it gonna be located did you
like that sound marty that was amazing
that was kind of crazy yeah yeah that
was that was sick i thought you're gonna
die
but yeah yeah i'm making a that's called
the gobcast the gods
guys
what a name
i don't know i just i was thinking of
other names and that one just flows so
good i love it of course it's perfect
yeah um as usual dope is yola goblin
gobcast it makes [ __ ] sense yeah it's
like yeah
play on your own [ __ ] yeah marty came up
with this name oh thank you
i already came up with the name of this
yeah we did a lot of brainstorming
yeah
kind of for the same reason like with
yours we wanted it to kind of pop up
when people were searching yeah yeah
and be something that they could kind of
like identify so sick [ __ ] yeah gobcast
yes sir so
what are you planning on doing for
everyone out there yeah i'm excited as
[ __ ] too for everyone out there what are
you planning on doing where are you
going to try to put it at is going to be
videos it's going to be sound only no
i'm definitely going to try to do some
video aspect of it i mean at first it's
going to have to be a digital thing like
video calls but i've been kind of
clearing out my uh for guests yeah for
guests and stuff otherwise um i've been
kind of clearing out my living room at
my house and i'm just gonna like make it
a podcast studio
and just like film in there
because i have a camera already and
stuff i just need to get lighting and
like you know some other cool [ __ ] um i
could just do it in my living room
so
i i never sit down there no one uses
that [ __ ]
so [ __ ] let's go i mean i already have a
cool couch i could just you know it's
only for you yeah yeah i could just sit
on the couch and smoke weed and just
like do the podcast there you know and
then like if there's like a local guest
be like yo you want to come to my
[ __ ] suburban ass illinois town and
sit on my couch and you know dudes you
guys they say yeah then sure but um
yeah i mean i think i think it's going
to be a lot of fun in terms of like what
i'm going to do on it i don't i don't
really want to say too much yet yeah of
course you know but i think it's going
to be a lot of fun
a lot of weeds can be smoked
so
where can people find it right now
before it's even out right now on
youtube uh i made a channel for it the
gobcast the space
g-o-b-c-a-s-t yes
yes we made it before
i mean you made it before just in case i
did when you little [ __ ] wanted
to take the name before you can grab it
so that's why we're saying it here it's
already taken don't try it yeah i uh i
got that i'm uh got the twitter too
gonna be making that um i'll let you
know what the ad is for that i i'm i
can't say it on the podcast because we
got to make all the accounts for it but
well this comes out monday you have to
get it before monday anyway oh yeah okay
well i don't know i don't want to say a
name that's not available because i
haven't looked at all that oh for sure
for sure yeah so either way i'll be
making more accounts for it soon i'll be
plugging those on my youtube but i think
it's gonna be a fun one um like i i
texted you about i mean you're gonna be
my first guest on there so
yeah that's gonna be a fun episode it's
gonna be fun i'm trying to get worse
yeah yeah
it's gonna be fun i'm excited when do
you think you're going to start um it's
just beginning in may now yeah i'm
aiming for
probably around august oh okay so
sometime yeah yeah there's definitely
some time between it i've still got to
line up guests and you know kind of
figure out the format entirely of what
i'm doing
um
but i mean at the same time most of my
videos and like all the content i do is
just kind of getting stoned and winging
it so it's kind of the theme i'm going
to maintain on the podcast
like i mean i of course i want to have
like returning things that i do on each
episode like i i feel like some of my
older video series i could kind of
incorporate segments on it like uh
that's what's on well that and also uh i
did a rating weed series right people
would send in weed and they'd like tell
them if i said you know no it's pictures
pictures i tell them if it was
you know i'd rate it out of 10. you know
i'd be like hey that's decent like yeah
that shit's awful i swear it's for
educational purposes officer they're
shipping me weed i didn't
that's why i don't have a p.o box
because that would be the most federal
thing ever we talked about this before
yeah i don't have one either because i
don't want
to open it it's just like dude people
are going to mail us so much goddamn
weed and other [ __ ]
someone's going to mail me math like for
sure and i don't i don't want to collect
meth from my p.o box and go to prison
no because that's what will happen yes
yes
well it depends man somebody could just
send you to anything you can't just go
to well you have to once you accept the
package you're on the hook pretty much
that's dumb though i could be just
picking up it is really dumb but
you have to uh like not take in the
package in order to prove that you
weren't anticipating it so you didn't
order it
i mean obviously if you have a good
lawyer you'll be able to get out of it
but just on a base level they will
charge you if you take the package
that's [ __ ] dumb yeah
um
okay so podcasts coming very soon
gobcast on youtube everybody can go
subscribe to that [ __ ] now
um
nice i'm excited for that
me too i i think it's gonna be a lot of
fun i um
i'm gonna try to have some fun guests on
there you know uh i i think the theme i
want to maintain is like i'm gonna have
a lot of my friends on there like from
the um
stories yeah like from the stories and
[ __ ] oh cause you're local yeah yeah so
like i plan on like calling up a lot of
my friends being like yeah you wanna
get stoned and you know hop on i think
it'll be fun i love that yeah
because people always ask you should get
this first on the phone yeah i mean i've
had i've had quite a few of my friends
like in my videos before but people
always ask about it and i feel like it
it kind of adds like a
a new layer to it when i bring someone
else on because like they'll always
remember [ __ ] that i don't you know
every time yeah
even though you have a vivid story
yeah i always think i remember every
detail of it and i don't yeah every time
there's probably just how it is every
story everyone's memory is different
um
that's awesome dude so you're thinking
august so but right now everybody go
subscribe to that right now
yes sir all right cool [ __ ] yeah um
so i saw what i did for this episode
since you've been on here a few times
and i wanted to keep it
somewhat story themed
um pardon me hold on hold on actually
before we start that
before we go into my next topic
i saw him already flash something up on
the screen a couple minutes ago oh
what'd you pull up i saw something he's
got a couple of light mother [ __ ] fan
questions fan questions fan questions
here we go not the oh yeah okay
okay all right at dope as usual podcast
on instagram
you pop coming in real quick so i can
see what you're talking about let's see
here we got a couple we got a couple
good ones here
hell yeah
fan questions man cause like i said
everyone's memory is different they're
gonna remember some [ __ ] that i'm like i
don't remember that at all dude some
people comment and they're like they'll
be like oh i remember uh like i'll talk
about something on stream they'll be
like oh you made a video about this and
i'll be like what and i'll go like look
through my like i'll type in like the
title like the drug and i'll be like
you know
be like what bro i've made so many
videos about so much [ __ ] that i've done
that like you can't remember it all
it just [ __ ] blows my mind dude yeah
you can't remember it all dude like what
was it little wayne google's his own
lyrics to make sure he didn't say it
already i feel that [ __ ]
awesome i feel that [ __ ] i feel it
like nowadays before i make a video i go
through my videos to make sure i haven't
like discussed something before stories
sometimes like when i go through some of
my like older videos i'll be on there
and i'll be like what the [ __ ] i talked
about this already yeah i'll be like
what like i don't remember making this
[ __ ] exactly
yeah it'd be that way sorry go go go
oh okay here we go
all right
here we go we got
swap meet princess swap me
do princess have any ghost stories i
think ghosts stories ghost stories
have you ever encountered some ghosts
[ __ ]
i don't
honestly think i have
on all the drugs and all the vibrations
and all the frequencies you have never
experienced anything
i mean that's great you don't you don't
force it i'm just saying wow that's
[ __ ] shocking
when i was like
really young
i the only thing ever is like it was
kind of weird
i don't know if it was like a ghost
thing or like what it was but like i
remember my my grandma was like in the
hospital
um
like my my great grandma i was like
three years old bro and like she was in
the hospital and she like just got in
there and like she was doing completely
fine i made some comments i was like oh
she's gonna die like
she died the same day
like that i said that she was doing
completely fine like six hours earlier
and like not a ghost story i don't know
it was kind of spooky paranoid somebody
a ghost story
yeah that's kind of [ __ ]
technically it is a ghost story so far
what i thought you were about to say my
grandma you know she was in there and i
saw some ladies just fled imitating and
i thought well she must be a ghost
no this full [ __ ] wish death upon his
great-grandmother she died i was like oh
i didn't understand i was like oh she's
my parents are like she's very sick and
i was like oh she's gonna die dude like
you know and like gonna die anywhere
i wasn't that casual about it i don't
know i was eating you're three years old
with a bowl cut out
did you have a bowl cut no i had really
short hair actually yeah
no i had super short hair when i was
young because i uh when i was young i
played a lot of football so i had
shorter hair for my helmets not buzz but
you know just not as much as i have now
uh
i i wouldn't say that's a ghost i didn't
play football knows three though
he had to clarify
he didn't
make the team
it's kind of like og's story of like you
want to talk about the time you gave the
men edibles and then he died dude oh gee
gave some guy edibles one time and he
died
legitimately he's dead and he was in the
cemetery
oh gee this guy lg's friend his dad had
like stage four cancer
brain catches on his way out
he's in hospice right okay
and og used to make these craziest
strong he makes the strongest rso i've
ever seen in my life okay
but he was making these crazy hash
brownies at the time like wild i can't
remember their hashbrowns or wheat but
anyway he made him so strong that people
were like hallucinating getting [ __ ]
up
this man's in hospice right he's on his
way out
he gave him a couple edibles and the guy
[ __ ] he multiple
he was gonna die but he went out so high
no that guy didn't even know he died god
think i was blessed that's what i'm
saying like wow oh gee felt terrible
that guy was on jupiter
that's the term that's a real dimension
you said yes so i thought you guys both
knew about the strength i said that
confidently enough that now it's a place
yeah marty you pulled an og on me right
now you got me
you [ __ ] i thought i was on some
[ __ ] that nobody like the k-hole right
yeah i was like damn marty why do you
know about superman
videos [ __ ] [ __ ]
so
you killed your grandma
i'm just kidding i don't have any other
ghost story zone okay right now that's
my grandmother even that i just kidding
you killed your grandma and he goes i
don't have any other ghosts
nothing did he react you're a murderer
no that's sad i pee that's sad i've done
that before too though she was real to
somebody else and they died
yeah it's [ __ ] up but i was like 19.
so it wasn't three whether you said it
or not it would have happened though so
i don't know it was only like five your
words didn't make it more oh no no no no
you know no but just the fact that i
said it he did oh
that's
terrible you ever watch those movies
about like diseases and [ __ ] the [ __ ]
pandemics like oh okay okay we mean like
philadelphia no
no
no so you've never seen like contagion
or anything like that no i don't like to
watch anything negative oh
such good movies dude
i always think about that [ __ ] when i
get stoned like i always think like this
is about people dying of discontent no
like diseases go around like you know
like covet for example but like worse
you know like and it's like plague yeah
that type of [ __ ] that sounds terrible
why are you watching that that's what's
moving
cool movie i mean horror movies dude
you're watching oh [ __ ] no that's why i
don't like horror movies i don't watch
too many of them but like i don't mind
them much like if it's a good hormone
i just choked yeah it's like
um if it's a good it had to be that way
if it's a good horror movie like i'll
watch it you know the last horror movie
i watched was the new it only because i
[ __ ] with kim tim curry it's when i
was a kid and i liked it that was an
okay i watched the redo's remakes other
than that i haven't watched a horror
movie since freddie versus jason it was
okay i i kind of liked it
i'm good
oh didn't watch the sequel
i don't care if it's spoiler alert
tim curry it
the it from the 90s
shits on the new one so violently
tim curry's funny if you don't know who
jim curry is he's the bad guy from home
alone too that takes the card and smiles
like the grinch at the hotel he is also
the guy from legend that plays the
[ __ ] devil
all right tim curry is also the guy from
rocky horror picture show sweet
transvestite
the [ __ ] uh
the guy uh-huh that's his character
i know chicago he's all over the place
love him tim curry is the man he's all
over the place
but tim curry it
is good have you seen the old it no bro
the newer one
those are scarier because he is so
[ __ ] goofy and funny and he just goes
into this character of scary it
and it's [ __ ] frightening anyway the
new it the end of number two you don't
have to watch it they bully him to death
really they bully it to death and i've
never felt more dumb
he killed it you're stupid oh
he's like melting from their insults
dude you could have just spoiled it too
for a lot of fans i do not give a [ __ ]
if you've waited this long to watch it
too you can there could be some major it
to supporters who just haven't had what
if they're in like they're not that
major you haven't seen the [ __ ] no what
if they're in like an impoverished
country and they can't afford it too yet
like like but they can stream this and
watch youtube yeah cause youtube's free
you can if they're in other countries
you can watch other movies on other
sites if they got the internet
what if they haven't figured it out yet
they haven't found the site he's really
into this hacker like like you gotta
feel spoiler alert and i even said at
the beginning i don't care if i spoil it
for you [ __ ] that movie was
stupid number one was cool the new hit
number two was [ __ ] dumb
and i'll leave it at that but yeah the
way you the way you described that made
it sound really stupid do you ever see
the new spider-man
yeah it was tight really good actually i
don't normally like superheroes i don't
really know that [ __ ] was fire i'm like
oh my god he's old i really want to see
the new doctor strange this comedy yeah
isn't that the guy that plays the
voldemort dude um
benedict cumberbatch or whatever is that
the same guy that plays him does he play
voldemort i don't know i could be wrong
but i watched a movie last night or two
nights ago and the doctor strange the
new one was in the screen i go that's a
[ __ ] voldemort i think
could be wrong it might be could be he's
played a lot of roles he's very he's a
very good actor yeah he's a good actor
uh i talked to you about this before we
started real quick this has nothing to
do with any of my [ __ ]
any of my topics or any of my questions
marty i watched a movie in theater the
other day i told
him before we started the show
guys
you guys i might go watch the [ __ ]
again if i have some i don't have any
time this week but i wouldn't want to go
watch it again i watched a movie called
everywhere or everything everywhere all
at once or everywhere everything either
one
you didn't tell me i talked to you right
before you went to see it right
you know i [ __ ] love movies
there was about 15 minutes after that
movie i didn't say anything i was just
thinking it hit you that hard i was just
thinking like
i told him like
ah maybe writing's great just bless you
it's not funny thank you because i can't
write that
i couldn't write that or direct that
[ __ ]
eat that [ __ ] that was too good i don't
know what to do i gotta see that [ __ ] if
it really hits you that hard i was just
sitting there that's cool it's a south
korean movie yeah
it was in subtitles
for like a lot of it a lot of those
south korean like movies and shows have
been going crazy lately dude
they did they did squid game it's a
south korean thing
yeah i watched that it was it was good
i believe it was south korea i think
um battle royale yeah
dude that [ __ ] was it was actually never
all right i i mean i don't want to spoil
it but don't
go watch this go watch it's a great
movie don't talk about squid game
oh i'm talking about it i'm not going to
spoil anything else either way we'll
just move past okay squiggly is cool no
yeah cool but i wasn't a fan of the end
that's all i'll say yeah i was a little
more like don't lead me onto another
[ __ ] yeah yeah yeah i'm pissed
i'm out i got [ __ ] to do
piss me off i don't i don't know i was i
just kind of started moving my head i'm
gonna start doing every time someone
calls me like you speak
[ __ ] you
they're like yo this feels crazy i
thought you were fake typing
fast fake typing to like
violence that's what i thought you were
doing sorry for everyone that's not
watching oh he's spotify we got video on
spotify
that's sick that's it
dude i feel like squid game should have
been a movie
it could have been easier it would have
been a really good movie if it was just
a movie you know yes good three hour
movie damn i didn't realize it wasn't a
[ __ ] movie no it's no it's a series
and they're making a second one it looks
like i don't want to watch that no i
don't either shows like movies like that
make me upset when people get hurt for
nothing it bugs me
like when you talk about fresh that [ __ ]
bugs i i watched um
this show recently on netflix it's uh a
show from the same place it's like a i
believe a korean show um
i think so um
and it's about this like zombie outbreak
that happens in a school
and like the high schoolers like they're
like barricading themselves in the class
like fighting off the zombies and [ __ ]
and it's it's actually a pretty good
show like the first season kind of bangs
i don't know man
i just can't wait it's fire oh you know
what i watched part of walking dead
walking dead was okay at first and then
they cut those fools throats at the
thing and were eating the people and i
stopped watching it i can't watch
[ __ ] get hurt like that i oh
dude that is a brutal show like very
good zombies and earth dying was fine
but watching people get murdered like
that yes
yeah
oh my gosh shows not what i wanted
zombies honestly if i was like acting
like that and seeing all the zombies
chase me i'd be scared of [ __ ] in real
life bro i'd be like what the [ __ ] even
though i knew it was acting like oh oh
oh yeah i'd be like oh my [ __ ] god
like this is horrifying bro dude
imagine one of the people who has to die
like yo it's your turn
there's like a horde on you like
that's terrifying like [ __ ] no i'm off
the show
i'm off the show even though you're not
dying it's still scary
i disappeared into the woods
left the camp [ __ ] it make an alternate
story
oh
oh
that is a weird thing to act out dying
yeah yeah it's like a zombie horde too
yeah
that's like that's [ __ ]
ugh yeah let's get off this
sorry i started thinking about horrible
ass scenes if you took a dark turn down
the horror movie path last night oh i'm
good you ready let's talk about stuff
highlight
[Music]
[ __ ] these zombies
what if the cure for being the cure for
zombies was like cocaine or something
and you had to make him like [ __ ] hit
a rail and they turned into just like yo
i'm deteriorating we just make like a
like a cocaine gun or something
uh-huh
uh-huh lick them with it
or no no we make it spread like a
flamethrower that's like a tank that's
not coke at that point
you're killing them it's cut they only
need a small amount
it's kind of [ __ ] cut with the fire
it's like five percent coke yeah
but like
let me think about it we get it we still
care we get a kilo put it in there
that's so much sorry youtube
i mean we are talking about this zombie
and obviously apocalypse yeah cure
withdrawals you'd only do that if you
two didn't exist anymore so oh [ __ ]
no they're just gonna get so upset at us
you talked about drugs but also in a
false statement you peace [ __ ] you're
kidding me pineapple shirts yeah because
it was a wholesome episode okay oh real
quick before we get into the drugs
how come you were here a couple months
ago yeah why didn't you tell us you were
going to be the riddler in the new
batman
how come you didn't tell anybody your i
i don't think you understand how many
times i've gotten that comment i saw the
movie right when it came out i do look
like him kinda i see it i see it i wear
the theater went like this
looked at rose she went
what the [ __ ]
dude even emily said that everyone who
saw the movie said that get out
they're going for that look
they saw his page would just make his
hair a little longer
they should have called me they should
have called you like hey bro
i'll murder her i murder i'm crazy hey
bro i would have been like a stunt
double for the riddler like no you
didn't actor and imagine you
[ __ ] like
i'll be the riddler next movie i'll do
it
that would be so sick and then after i
watched i went on twitter the first
thing i saw was you like yo guys so i
didn't want to let you know that i'm
[ __ ] in the new batman
[ __ ] up the second i got out of the
theater that's what i saw from his own
account dude everyone was saying that
[ __ ] to me it's so funny
yeah pretty funny that movie we talked
about last night yeah
yeah
it was it was all right
good moments
how have i never done this
wow as a holder while i get into wow
what's going on that's that's what
you're like brandon basketball collab
with some weed what the hell
is ball or how have i never done this in
my life see that's how i feel it
some josh cousins
dude i can't believe it so i want to buy
something that's some of the coolest
[ __ ] these are unreleased are you ready
okay from the dopashop.com the prototype
all right you guys ready
oh [ __ ] the dope is our company
these are green apple but oh it's
already hurting right here knowing how
sour this is you should have seen thomas
react yesterday i had the first glimpse
on facetime these are just as sour as a
warhead are you serious so be a little
cautious eat as a small bite and see if
it's okay for you
it's pretty
[ __ ] sour
oh my god oh my god right
my whole mouth is like salivating going
bro
my jaw is like locked
you want one
well you want one
there's so much [ __ ] god
these are coming out soon green sour
apple
did you say i take them
oh [ __ ]
oh [ __ ] they're good
that was a [ __ ] sour
i will say it's not too sour warheads
are worse than that oh
maybe i ate too many yesterday
yeah i could see like
oh bad being kind of dangerous but these
are just the first level
we have extreme sour too
maybe i'm mixing them up
what but that's sour bro i'm sweating
no that's really like
i like
puckered up
you [ __ ] sorry for asmr chewing
again enjoy everyone
sorry these really don't even seem like
weed candy they're just straight
no yeah that's just a candy the sour
really like gets rid of any sort of like
taste other than just candy
and the green apples are fine bro look
at this
[Laughter]
sorry sorry here we go
shark
bomb as [ __ ]
are you ready yep
back into it
why did you start doing drugs i went
through your [ __ ] story why i started
doing drugs
tell us
when i was younger i mean uh
at first i was just i got into high
school and i had done pretty much
nothing up to that point like i was a
very like um tame kid you know i didn't
do i had bad grades i just played video
games but like are you an only child
yeah
yeah
and my parents are divorced and they
both work all the time so i had the
house myself all the time
and as you get older i mean
obviously you're gonna start having
people over and doing [ __ ] like that
um
and as i gotten older
i
at first i was just drinking a little
bit you know smoking some weed which i
feel like a lot of kids did in high
school you know i mean everyone gets
stoned at drinks in high school i feel
like for the most part
and if not they do it in college you
know
um
but
when i when i started doing that stuff i
kind of put that over my school
and started getting shittier grades and
i had a bad relationship with my parents
already to begin with
dude this [ __ ] so innovative
[Laughter]
sorry but uh no either way
when i was younger i um
i just kind of like
didn't want to be home much you know i
didn't have a great relationship with
either of my parents we argued a lot
because of my grades and [ __ ] like that
so from what it is i would go out when i
was even before i started doing drugs
you know like you're 10 and you'd argue
with your parents no it's like 13 14 you
know dude you're [ __ ] yeah okay i was
i was a pretty good kid like when i was
young i was i was actually a pretty good
kid
but
as i got older i just kind of stopped
giving a [ __ ] about school and started
going out more and
you know i grew up like like i told you
earlier in a pretty good area like i was
i wasn't like i was pretty well off you
know um
my parents like they had their own like
nice places you know they they drove
like their own cars you know so um
i more so just didn't have a good
relationship with them so i started
going out more and making friends that
did a lot more [ __ ] than me you know
they uh after i i started drinking and
smoking the next drug i did after that
was xanax
um
have you ever done it no
ain't good
good
good
yeah i'm not a pill i don't like pills
but ecstasy the thing with xanax is
it's super hard to kick
and it's also like a super common thing
because like people treat it so casually
you know it's having their house people
yeah people just like yeah like then
calm down i used to do a lot of that
[ __ ] i've gone through like phases of
taking it
but i first tried it back then um and
once i started doing xanax you know i i
feel like the reason i mean they started
it is just because like i was so [ __ ]
bored you know what drugs are i i didn't
have [ __ ] to do i mean at least when you
think about growing up in the midwest
and [ __ ] there's nothing to do bro like
you go to the movie theater
you go to a restaurant or you go home
that's so goddamn boring
though that's a loop yeah yeah any any
like suburban town is just it's so
boring and like you know we didn't have
a lot of money back then so i started
doing
a lot of bad [ __ ] to make money you know
i i started like getting arrested for
stuff i started getting in trouble at
school i got since the alternative
school um and once it had gotten to that
point i i kind of looked at it in the
sense of like yeah i i have so much [ __ ]
that i've already done that i'm in
trouble for my grades already so bad i'm
probably not graduating on time anyways
i'd have to do an extra year and i'm not
willing to
i just kind of said [ __ ] it and went
like crazy with the drugs
um
this was prior to when i went to rehab
um and that kind of changed my
perspective a little bit i still went on
a few rampages after that but it'd be
that way um were your parents hard asses
were they like always the brick wall my
dad was a hard ass but he was like
really stupid like he was really like
just not
um aware of much so i could get away
with a lot my mom
um like i've told you before she she
works as a [ __ ] like counselor for
like
teens who are addicted to drugs and [ __ ]
so she literally works in like the field
that like like i'm her i'm almost a
prime customer pretty much so
yeah she like knew a lot was really onto
what i was doing so she would get really
mad at me we had a bad relationship
granted i was also an [ __ ] when i was
doing a lot of those drugs um
but also if you just did your grades
were they cool
if i got better grades
i don't know if they would have been
i don't think that you about other [ __ ]
besides the grades because yeah it was
it was drugs more than grades at that
point
i'm talking about before when it was
just oh before it was just grades if i
got better grades would they have been
yeah yeah oh so you were the little kid
i was like do your [ __ ] like no yeah
you're a little [ __ ] yeah okay so now
once i started doing drugs when i
started doing actual bad [ __ ] and then
they had an actual like reason you know
we started really i get it uh prior to
that it was just like a very you know
whatever kind of thing i had some bad
grades here pissed whatever you know
good [ __ ] yeah exactly um
but i i just started going out a lot
doing a lot of [ __ ] um getting in a lot
of trouble i crashed a few cars when i
was younger
um
you've heard about that yeah yeah i know
but your own no just your mom's
somebody on some i
i only heard your mom's you crashed your
mom's car and you felt bad because it
was hers
right a honda
the
wrapped it around a fence or something
the accord so that was that was uh that
was actually my dad's car not my mom oh
your dad's um yeah i i was driving
through a neighborhood and i [ __ ]
it was raining out and i took a turn
really fast because i was like racing
one of my buddies how stupid is [ __ ] um
dude i was in a honda accord racing my
friend through a suburban neighborhood
at like 9 00 pm i'm i was stupid but
it was it was just like the roads were
really wet and i was young and i took
this turn really fast and i i slid off
the road and wrapped my car around a
tree
but everyone inside was okay the car
wasn't
so yeah you told us this one yeah yeah
that thing was [ __ ] so they had every
right to be like yo stop
yeah for a while for a while i just
didn't i didn't have a car um
and now that i'm older obviously i don't
do that kind of [ __ ] anymore i'm a lot
more like regular with the driving but
my insurance is [ __ ] because of all
that stuff
it's so bad people don't realize stop
doing st stupid [ __ ] when you're younger
in cars yeah no it comes back it comes
back dude my insurance is like more than
if i wanted to go lease a car right now
damn near like a cheap car not a nice
one your insurance oh you also live in
the midwest so it's probably lower than
normal and the normal rate's probably
it's probably it's much lower than here
i think we've talked about this before
your insurance is what how much a month
i [ __ ] lot how much like
it was over 500 eight and then now it's
like seven or eight six oh
it's a lot bro but it's also because of
that car that's so painful oh it hurts
me every day that's so awful and it
sucks
wow
it's like
it's like you're paying one of their
employees almost when they're like call
center like oh
my insurance for the uh
yes
and i also live where i live
and i have a point of my record go to
driving school
let's go to driving school all right i
promise you it'll save you
1500 a year in insurance just that
little [ __ ] discount
they give you a discount for that
no but if i didn't have a point i would
have a little bit oh
insurance
oh you just had [ __ ] going to driving
school and just well i just left it i
just [ __ ] forgot about the [ __ ] it
happened sometimes does that point ever
expire i don't know
god it's still there i had two
oh
i forgot about the ticket that's [ __ ]
i see this car i haven't taken this car
did you print out fake insurance
why she can fake out the cops so we get
pulled over
and not go you know what if i'm gonna
get in trouble for fraud no
fraud him
fraud do what you gotta do my luck
government doesn't like me i think they
me every social media account everything
i try to do do you think that's the
government i don't know but everything i
ever try to do in life that's what we're
blaming yeah marty okay you heard me go
i'm at the bank
oh you guys have heard the bank story
you've heard
12 other things my social security
number every time i go that it doesn't
match your name go i have this [ __ ] it's
worked my whole life and now i'm not in
the system it's the truman show god
[ __ ] with you a hundred percent he's
going
sell out for me sell
and then and then he's going to rock the
boat that's why i'm going to ship it go
in the water wow look at your circle
that's why i don't go with water yeah
there's someone out there to go
turn
so therefore
i probably would
thank you
full circle no thank you sir those
joints are fire dude i'm pretty stoned
oh yeah got i got another one for us
right now oh beautiful news that's such
amazing news
that's magic okay so that's the story of
why you start doing drugs sounds like a
lot of our stories pretty much yeah i
mean i wasn't necessarily like uh i
didn't have like i would say like a
troubled childhood i mean i didn't have
a great relationship with my parents but
a lot of people have that you know
a lot of people always blame like i did
drugs my dad was such a dick like my mom
was all [ __ ] no i i mainly did it
honestly because i had the freedom to
like i just took advantage of it like my
parents were never home i would have
people over and just hang out with
people i am lucky yeah i'd call my
homies be like yo my mom's not home
until eight come over let's make edibles
[ __ ] get make edibles yeah you're a
risky ass dude
she'd come home pissed as hell
she comes you have a different
relationship my mom would have
once the one time no she'd like throw me
out for that a few times stabbed i um
oh no not for real stab she punched me
in the mouth no shoot my mom wouldn't
hit me that's why we talked about she
she would kick me and that's why
all right i'll stay gone for a couple of
days but if it came with that i woke up
and she was standing over me telling me
the new rules of the house and then i
was like all right i'll start [ __ ]
doing it
that's a different upbringing yeah
definitely
i slept in a car for a few days man by
the beer
yeah yeah uh yeah i had a buddy uh he
just did it with me volunteering i'll do
it with you he's like yeah
[ __ ] to do yeah we had a super wealthy
friend who had a boat uh his dad's boat
parked at the pier and he like
he had his access code so we could get
in and just sleep in the parking garage
it was like gated secure it's like it
wasn't a garage it was just like right
on the water so we just chill there you
know uh and sleep in the car
mcdonald's for breakfast every day
shower planet fitness type [ __ ] you know
go driver suburbs american life
back then twenty dollars was a full tank
of gas bro you can really do that [ __ ]
it trips me out every single time i buy
something
dude inflation's hitting different right
now bro oh no i meant like what twenty
dollars would go when you were seventeen
oh at the people oh for sure
now you're like
as a tip for my movement for my food
yeah and it's so weird that it's twenty
dollars is like oh
twenty dollars is nothing anymore almost
it's still treated like it is but it
goes so much faster now that you're an
adult you have a business you're doing
this
you're buying merch you're [ __ ]
paying for your car you're doing yep
it's like
17. no 20 dollars just disappears bro
like 20 dollars back when i was a kid i
got a that's a bag of weed that's
[ __ ] here
yes yes or wendy's
we never win these buyers but oh but we
would just go like yo i got seven
dollars that's seven things you got some
change six big chickens bro
don't charge me taxes let me get seven
you know what i'm saying like you'll
change because it's gonna be more than
seven yep yep that's how we would do it
bro no for real
[ __ ] i remember when i was stoned with
my friend my friend had to make chicken
competition oh my god you guys are
wealthy
no dude back in high school we were we
were selling like a little bit of weed
so we'd have like some money not
anything crazy like literally we get
like an ounce and like you sell a house
yeah we gotta get ounces still having
like smoke half when i was on probation
and stuff i sold a little more weed you
know i think i've told you about that
before i got some stuff in the mail um
but i remember one time my friend went
to mcdonald's and we were like yeah we
should just get like 20 mcchickens and
just see which of the two of us can eat
more you just watch harold kumar
uh i've seen it but we didn't just watch
it we were just stoned as [ __ ] we just
like
yeah let's go do it we should do it so
we went to mcdonald's and we got like 20
they were pissed bro we ordered and i
remember the lady she was like are you
joking and like we're like no like can
we get 20 chickens there's not even a
lot of fish she's not even making it
that's dude they're so easy put a piece
of chicken on that [ __ ]
i worked mcdonald's the easiest [ __ ] you
can make is to make chicken really
it's one [ __ ] thing with the [ __ ]
lettuce and man yeah it is super easy
it's not like you ordered 20 like big
macs or anything that's a whole process
man yeah also knowing mcdonald's
we don't even get to see the ingredients
really no bro the secret to his cousin
the tube of a caulking gun like when you
do caulking so you just you just shoot
it on there yes and you pump it through
the back you twist it like a caulking
gun
that's [ __ ] you don't want to eat the
[ __ ] the mayonnaise same [ __ ] process
no don't [ __ ] with it don't [ __ ] with it
yeah that egg i've never seen a really
mcdonald's somebody come somebody yeah
don't do like uh the breakfast like egg
patties that come in just like yeah but
i like that i've had people say no i
work at mcdonald's we use real eggs i'm
like yo you're rich as [ __ ] because i
yeah
curtain until you pour them
that's don't eat mcdonald's dude i i
will say when i worked at wendy's
they're pretty clean with it what is
different they have actual meat besides
the chili don't eat on shelly from
wendy's you were saying that the first
time we talked about it you know i will
say that so i [ __ ] die i will never
let someone do that
you can't order if you're with me i will
stop it
i'll throw it out the window
all right chilling last night
not from air but it's funny when you
said that i was thinking i haven't eaten
chili since i was thinking wendy's chili
oh my god chili is fire dude yo what
happened marty's rolling a joint in the
silence
where are we talking about windows
chilling i'm a little high it's probably
like one i'm pretty stoned that's my
first smoke in the day
all right hold on let's smoke a little
joint hell yeah i got a random question
for you oh wait we have fake questions
too keep going keep going
can you explain to me what the [ __ ]
kratom is
so kratom it's um thank you it's kind of
described sometimes as a natural opiate
it's like oh god disgusting i i
personally dislike it i don't really do
it i hate it honestly um
if a kratom company paid me the right
price i'd promote it though but well um
no i'm kidding i'm kidding everyone i'm
kidding everyone he looks
dude
um oh hell yeah i should have ate food
before we started a show
come on beer edibles and weeds
i know
[Music]
wait
you flew
in mm-hmm
did you see the billboard
no i didn't oh where'd you go because we
had to take the shuttle to the uh hurts
place
oh then you went right by it
did we
on the shuttle
oh i couldn't see out the windows like
that i picked it because it goes
straight from the airport to the [ __ ]
car places and you have to cross it
everybody oh i couldn't see it from the
butt bro i'll see you when i drive back
yep let's go
that's so sick kratom
kratom is [ __ ] disgusting it's um
it's like a natural opiate um
some personally with me i've never
gotten super like high off it it makes
me more nauseous and uncomfortable than
anything i get cold sweats um you do get
somewhat of an opiate feeling where you
feel really light headed almost and like
you you feel very like cloudy
no no
you uh so there's different ways to do
it you can make tea with it you can just
take it in capsules um concentrated form
of it where you can drink it
what did you say
it's the kratom yeah yeah kratom dude
creative
it's one of my least favorite things
because it's never once made me feel
very good but like
it's addictive and people do get
addicted to it sometimes um it's like a
downer i have a friend who one time he
he got like an ounce bag of it and
kratom you have to take a lot of it to
feel anything so an ounce isn't like a
super insane amount of kratom but
he took a flower what is it so it's
ground up it's usually a powder or
concentrate i i believe before it's
ground up it is like a plant but they
won't just i mean i guess you could try
to find a plug for like a
kratom plan i'm not exactly sure
honestly
i mean i believe it's natural but i
haven't done it enough to know a ton
about it i only have like
maybe two videos about that [ __ ] yeah
it's been a long time for me it's one of
those things i did like because they
sell it at smoke shops it's legal so
yeah i remember i used to go to the
smoke shops with my friends in high
school we'd buy some and like drink it
you know we get the concentrated form
which is disgusting by the way it's like
this brown goop and you we drop it in
like a sprite and just chug it as fast
as we could
nastiest [ __ ] i've done like one of the
top five nastiest things ever like gross
almost as bad as like
putting like molly on your like tongue
if you've ever done that
oh it tastes like it tastes like uh
molly and i see it a little different
imagine what toxic waste tastes like oh
like a like a nuclear reactor
like you're licking the side of it like
it's just such a chemically overwhelming
taste it's disgusting
and does it [ __ ] you up right away and
then lastly
yeah um it it takes a little bit to [ __ ]
you up it lasts a little bit um
i mean i've personally i don't know if
it's because i've never done enough or
i've never done good enough quality of
it but i've never gotten super lit off
it but when i do feel something
it'll last me a good like three hours
four hours but it takes maybe about an
hour hour and a half to set in because
um
i mean you you do have to drink it or
you know however you consume it first
it's it's not really as quick as smoking
but you can't smoke crayon
i remember when i first did it i thought
that's how you did it because it's just
this little powder i was like this looks
like keef you know like what if we just
put this [ __ ] on a bowl don't do that
yeah the midwest is so boring midwest
sucks out they're doing crazy dude i'm
telling you if
if we didn't have chicago and illinois
we would be like in arkansas to your
state
like like a delaware to your state who
the [ __ ] lives in delaware
yeah that's a fair point
they've been saying this should be like
two dudes should be like two dudes in
the comments like yo i live in delaware
stuff they're [ __ ] you thank god
get this guy off
who is this guy he's a drug addict
deleted before delete this episode
yo
marty yeah
thank you for asking next i don't know
what the [ __ ] it was yeah i get it
confused with salvia completely yeah i
dude i gotta ask about salvia a lot
i'm never going to do salvia in my damn
life you've never done it no i've never
done it never do i've done it so much
oh
first time
i ever did it with my uncle john okay
out of the purple bomb damn he was into
that [ __ ] like that
he says i got to the smoke shop and it
says it makes you lose niggle
[Laughter]
let's try that [ __ ] john i was like 13
or 14. i was like 14.
we sit on the green plastic chairs with
the slits in the back yep
i'm sitting there
my back is too rite aid we said the
7-eleven we're at the if you know what
mercedes in the parking lot i mean the
apartments right behind rite aid and
7-eleven on the corner of g right next
to the high school
he smoked it and i looked at my uncle
john's a full-grown man
he's
25 at the time uh-huh
he hits it out of the bomb with a little
bit of weed on oh no no we it was just
black little flakes like fish food oh
is that what it looks like yeah it's
like a little grout like when i don't
know how to explain it it's like
flakes
it's weird looking okay
it stinks too i can smell salvia i know
that smell if i smell like oh someone's
smoking salvia in here
he smoked it
and he
started drooling the [ __ ] face i'm
looking at like oh my god oh my god are
you okay
he starts chuckling
and you still smoked it after witnessing
that yeah well i waited for him to come
out of it he went like 45 seconds later
he goes
what the [ __ ]
oh my god are you okay guys yeah you
should try it it should that was crazy
i trust you
and i packed me up one i packed me one
i hit it and i just felt like my whole
world go
small and i felt like my head fell back
and when it fell back it felt like it
extended
and like
you know in movies where there's a
camera in someone's face they're going
like
hella fast they're going through scenes
but it's just them like in the middle
yeah
that's how my head felt and it felt like
i it went all the way to right hand i
even told my head just smacked rite aid
that's [ __ ] and they made he made fun
of me forever i'm like but you were
drooling and i say my head smacked right
and i'm in the [ __ ] you're drooling
in your backyard on your porch sorry
front here
and uh
that's the first time i smoked salvia
and then i started getting salvia
whenever we could that's dude salvia
they sold it in smoke shops yeah it's
legal right now it's still legal yeah
it's legal i didn't know that we got the
20x and then one time
we stepped it up we got the 50. there's
like 100 150 i think there's a hundred
and something like 100 strength
yes oh jesus christ so the salvia
stories i've done on storytelling of
course on story time okay
with all my friends wearing the pizza
spot and we gas masked it up
duct taped his bong
to the gas mask and salvia through that
through it because we're like yo we got
the 100 at 90x or 100x 90 or 100.
and we packed full bowls of it and all
of us did it i lost my mind
my friends are all tripping everyone i
won't go into full detail because it'll
take forever yeah dude i was somewhere
else i was talking to a person
i thought i was in another place
i was this small on my own hat that was
in my hands it's like
the fastest mushroom trip pushed in
together because it only lasts about 40
seconds that's terrifying it was that's
terrifying but it was great when it was
fun and i had one bad one
once and i would never do it again
because of that that was your last last
time
those with my brother my cousin rosie
and me at the circle brown table for the
push trees house i smoked it all i kept
seeing myself was getting up and jumping
headfirst into my bathroom door through
it and hiding what that's all i kept
seeing in my head playing over and over
and over like i gotta get out of here
and i just kept thinking like i'm
freaking out
and then i just kept singing at my head
and then i like snapped into him like i
didn't dive through the bathroom door
[ __ ] salvia i had a bunch of it left i'm
like you guys can keep it and i never
did it again that was like they smoked
the rest of that [ __ ] my brother did
what strength was that do you remember
the 90 100 too because i only go that
only go right there because anything
below that you don't get the super
intense trips and i'm telling you i was
fully immersed mushroom
trip times 10
gone [ __ ] that sounds terrifying my
friend said he was swimming in a pool
and the devil was pulling him into a
into a lake or into a lake yeah and that
he was bad for doing drugs and his mom
knew and he was dying but we watched him
we all let one person do it at times so
we'd all be okay
and he did have the gas mask
and he was swimming on the ground i'm
like what the [ __ ] he's screaming and
he's swimming
like it looked like he was trying to do
laps and when he snapped out of it and
he's the ball fast mexican leo my
homie's a [ __ ] mma fighter now so
we're like yo
don't swing on us man
that's the story i told you he was just
like he's staring at us like this and he
was tripping like yeah he swings on us
what are we gonna do
we all can't take him all three of us
couldn't take [ __ ] leo yeah and like
it was a bad night that sounds horrible
it was bad i mean i get dude i get asked
to elvia all the time i'm never gonna
try it okay hold on
ever maybe i would do it again if we
were like yo
let's try salvia one more time yeah if
we're gonna film it hyper sick
and i'll do it i'll do that like a
podcast segment like no podcasting i'm
not gonna be able to continue after that
oh i'll be pissed at myself
i'll do it we could do like some b-roll
like some you know like
some b-roll
yeah
do it at the end of the last 40 minutes
five seconds is me
no because i'll be gone yeah your body
will be on autopilot the ashtray yeah
yeah yeah
because i told you one of the times i
got out of the trip i was on the other
side of the house i had got up and
walked through and you always think you
pissed yourself
once you come out you feel so hot on
your legs that's that sounds so awful
though every person who told me like i
thought i pissed myself like me [ __ ]
dude i just don't understand why like
you would never do it like because you
hallucinate so quick
it's like taking mushrooms but you come
back in less than a minute dude do it at
that but it's legal okay yeah and you're
fine after there's no hangover anything
it's just like you're like what the [ __ ]
was that why is it not as common anymore
why is it not sold like that
i mean yeah it is horrible but like some
of the [ __ ] they sell chops now is still
horrible i don't know but salvia got
played out if anybody smokes salvia
you're a champ i mean you remember when
they were selling that fake weed that k2
and [ __ ] in the shops and stuff yeah
i've never seen that [ __ ] before i've
strung that [ __ ] remember spice i smoked
spice a few times yeah that's like the
synthetic weed yeah
like that scooby-doo snack like that
scooby snack [ __ ] uncle john
i know a lot of drugs from uncle john he
was a grown ass man
yeah i did get him hooked on cocaine
though so that was nice we got one here
that's related to this
wholesome what does this mean this from
zooped ask goblin about the quaaludes in
africa what one time someone uh so i did
some research about finding quaaludes
and i found out that they still have
them in south africa
so i told my viewers that if i ever got
a passport i would go to south africa to
find quaaludes
so cool bring them shits back yeah oh
well no i'd have to take them there's a
federal crew i have to take them there
take them there legally i'd have to get
a prescription as a legal citizen or a
visitor of south africa that is ill it
needs quality
yeah flying to south africa faking an
illness to get no i'm not faking i'm not
faking i am uh i'm really going to be
ill
i'm going to get real sick before i go
real ill before i before i come through
100
i'm gonna be sick as [ __ ] i'm gonna get
sick first
i'm gonna do what i gotta do
i respect
i need to lose dude i'm gonna get myself
sick i mean i i don't know dude
quaaludes like i've just heard they're
just like the the omeca like they're
just oh you want a drug yeah
what you got some lewds like what thing
in my hand oh i just want to see your
face
i don't know i kind of lit up a little
bit i was like
oh drugs are they like ketamine
basically though
i don't know a ton about them it's kind
of hard to find infos they haven't been
around in a long time like quaaludes
have not been around since like what the
90s
yeah like yeah
i mean it's been like
20 something years now you're the dude
if anybody's gonna do this i have to do
this i have to [ __ ] do this and i
will at some point i will
i really want to i need the loot
i need those loots stand loose you
should make that mean
some girl pulling up her shirt and she
has [ __ ] playlist on her boobs cut
that so i can make that a shirt yeah
yo
uh-huh
sorry i'm just thinking about the
[ __ ] shirt now that's actually i can
see it [ __ ] goblin shirt i can see it
right now yeah some
outline drawing of a chick
has got quails and this is like alice in
wonderland or some [ __ ] it's a snow
white it's like how he would do it yeah
that's fire that's actually fire yeah
it's actually pretty [ __ ] cool i like
that that's sick um
any more fan questions
yeah we got hella [ __ ] fair oh [ __ ]
okay go for it because i got more
questions too let's go from uh tenacious
d
uh hold on hold on hold on let me let me
get a good one here from ox cereal where
are you oh don't [ __ ] on tenacious you
gotta say
now he's gonna be like all my questions
first of all his name is tenacious
dumbass all right
now you just put him on blast
and he said has there ever been a point
where you thought about getting
completely sober and that kind of passed
that one but i probably shouldn't have
because we've talked about it before
yeah i think we have yeah we've talked
about before but today's dumb ass
oh god saying your name sucks i'm sorry
yo we didn't leave me out all right
don't feel left out
sorry marty go you're a good guy man
nice guy what's the what's the weirdest
fan interaction that you've had
from it's blake double o
hmm
i mean i've definitely gotten some
really weird messages i get emails all
the time but like in person i haven't
had a ton of fan interactions in person
um i've probably been recognized maybe
five six times there's these guys who
work at a jimmy john's that i go to
sometimes
they've there's two of them it's like a
dude his cousin and dude
one of them made the best italian
sandwich i've ever had that guy snapped
bro i was like yeah this guy put it in
one of them made the best of talent
this guy went crazy bro this guy snapped
and he gave me like three free cookies
great guy um but then there was one time
i was at a gas station and there was
this guy just standing like in the back
of the gas station staring me down i
thought he was like gonna try to like
fight me or something i was like looking
i was like yeah like
shit's about to get real you know like
this guy's staring me down i went i went
to grab a drink
and this [ __ ] guy is like like over
the aisle i just see his head sticking
up and he's [ __ ] staring at me and
i'm like yo dude like what's going on
and i had to go to the atm to get some
money to buy weeds so like i i started
walking over to the atm and he walks up
to me while i'm at the atm and i'm like
yeah she's like like [ __ ] like
something's about to happen he's like
are you gobbling and i was like
at that point i was just like yeah you
know and he's like oh what's up and he
took a picture in front of the atm i
think he's the only one who has it i
don't know we took it on his phone um
and then he left
oh that's cool yeah yeah it would be
cool but like just the way it happened
at first i was like bro this guy's about
that was like me dude like he like
stared me down through the store then
waited until i was pulling money out to
walk up on me i was like yo this is it
dude he's gonna take my this is it
like shit's about to get serious
but no it was cool i haven't had like a
ton of weird ones i got bumped into uh
when i used to sell bathtubs one time
huh remember when i worked at that uh i
think i told you about this i worked at
a bathroom remodeling company is like oh
yeah so i uh i got bumped into one time
doing that job and this is back when i
had like you were doing a job i was like
so they would send me to different
locations to like try to get leads
basically i'd be at like a mall and i
just harassed people who would walk past
and be like yeah
come give me your number get a discount
bathroom remodel
stupidest business plan ever like so
stupid but they paid me well so i did it
this was like 2016-17
and they paid me like 12 dollars an hour
plus commission which was fire dude that
was like really good money back then
especially um
so i was doing that and i had like
no i had more than 10k actually i had
probably like 20k subs um and this guy
just walked up he's like are you
gobbling and i was like this is the
first time i'd ever been recognized i
was like what the [ __ ] dude it like [ __ ]
i was like what stuff like
like how this guy like at that point i
showed my face like one time like in one
video and i got like two thousand views
so like it was really weird that this
guy recognized me because i didn't have
an instagram my twitter had no pictures
of me on it i was like
[ __ ] like 16 at this point barely
made like
not even 100 videos yet you know
how many videos you have about now
like almost 500.
damn i'm at like 250.
yeah damn
that's a lot of videos bro yeah i mean i
made the channel in 2013
so
i've got quite a lot of
but i didn't really post
i i go i went through like phases with
it i still do i mean i try to be more
consistent now um
yeah yeah i mean i uploaded i kind of
spammed some uploads the past few days i
uploaded like five videos in the past
like six days holy [ __ ] yeah but
i got one more dropping actually
probably later today
but um
this this med card company hit me up so
i'm doing a video about that just about
the process and stuff are you giving me
like some info so i don't want them
where i like went to a spot they gave me
my thing dude i [ __ ]
[ __ ] said some confidential
information we shouldn't have said now
we're back okay um
yeah all right so some uploads that's a
lot of [ __ ] upload so you gotta
recognize there if that's
that's
odd when you're the first time i just
uploaded what the [ __ ] yeah dude i was
brand new to that [ __ ] back then i mean
i had 20k had just gotten out of rehab i
was like a moderately sober guy cage got
a rehab of 16.
i was like 17 no i
17 18 at the time
not quite 16 16 i was still in high
school but at this point i dropped out
already so
i just got you definitely like at least
18. um
marty
you have any more fan questions before i
move on
the other overwhelming fan question is
has goblin ever officially greened out
have i ever officially greened out i've
definitely gotten sick off smoking
before like
um
i mean my definition of a green out is
when you smoke some [ __ ] that that makes
you
uh you know when you get too high that
you get sick
yeah i don't know if i've ever gotten so
high that i've gotten sick from it but
i've smoked some garbage that like made
me sick you know that's different i
don't necessarily count it as a green
out though but i don't know
if i've ever necessarily gotten so high
that i just got sick i haven't uh
really hella rso oh yeah that'll do it
you know i did um oh god i don't
remember the amount it was like four do
you remember the amount
four thousand two hundred milligrams of
thc in the rso
how much
i did five like one grams or inches of
rso on a stream one time and they had
like 800 milligrams 850 of thc in each
of them
um and i was high for like two days
so at that point that was the closest
i've probably ever been
because i woke up the next day and i was
still super stoned and i was like bro
i've been a psychosis this is it
i i woke up and i was like damn bro
it's over you know
like i finally fried my brain you know
this is it um so i was terrified uh that
day and i remember i was just i was so
stoned that i was i was so like mentally
drained i was just talking so slowly
like i was on facetime talking to her
like this like how are you doing like
dude
i was out cold i used a picture of me
slumped out on the webcam on discord
from when i was like no way worse than
that i was like backwards bro oh that's
not the one i saw that was [ __ ]
i i had a a few of them that i've
utilized
really
they're clutch pictures dude are these
the nerds okay we have these coming out
dude i have not tried these yet
let's do it i haven't even tried them at
all let's do it let's uh let's do some
official research i haven't tried it at
all
those are cool they need to be more
the gummy needs to be stronger flavor
i agree all i taste is the nerds right
now i'm going to save i'm only tasting
nerds
sure
uh did we mention the adobe shop
instagram is back oh yeah
about the dopey shop
all one word the doba shop on instagram
it's back
we got that [ __ ] back thank you
publicist
those aren't good though they're good
they are gonna have more taste but if
the gummy tasted something like the
sharks or something that would be crazy
we can make it taste like whatever we
want oh that one was a little better
needs to be more consistent before we
lose that yeah yeah
we'll work on it
we will work on it what is that
it's a vape nicotine oh okay nicotine
you want some more
yeah i'll have another one
all right i'm sorry about that candy
drinking beer smoking weed
diet of champions
here we go there's my breakfast
this is the first time we're really
cracking open the dopest [ __ ] food
like this out here i know huh but we i
just got a whole [ __ ] care package in
to fill up for the [ __ ] anybody that
comes by so i got boxes of this [ __ ] all
lined up and organized
wait i got some more [ __ ] too oh i got
some more [ __ ]
we got more to go
let's go what do we got the van emoji
pre-rolls
they're fully keep we'll smoke those at
the end okay but yeah check it out let
me see this i still got a joint do you
want to or do you want to let's do this
yeah exactly i was gonna wait to smoke
these until these are gone and then yeah
yeah we gotta take care of these you
know how you know when you're burnt
oh when you grab the vape as a lighter
uh-huh
that's an early indicator it's not gonna
work this is a good way to start the day
i didn't smoke before i got here no it's
like what time is it now we got i got
here like a little before 11. you got
here like 10. that's like 1 30. 10 38
30. yeah
so we started at like what 11 no almost
12.
yeah we're at like 150 right now oh okay
we're two hours in usually you're
[ __ ] i'm ready for these this 11 a.m
is switching it up yeah
11 am we're kind of past two times
you've came you came after you've gone
to dinner with attila or eric and you've
drank the whole time so the past two
times
you have been shit-faced when you got
here
that's how it goes that's why we're like
we're all alert and talking about like
yeah [ __ ] in the ocean yeah we're like
alert
usually we're talking about at the
ankles [ __ ] up this time we just
really want to know what the ocean yeah
the weeds hitting different at this time
you know i do i feel ready to drive my
toyota camry thanks to hertz toyota
camry tesla [ __ ] pieces of [ __ ] for
order uh your season i want to ruin your
sponsorship chances with them or
anything
but like you never know do you ever know
who's gonna call what if they run an
influencer campaign
okay so you don't you know i'll work
with hurts
it hurts no that's okay okay [ __ ] hurts
dude it hurts is awful
cbs got a last podcast hurts is up cbs
can get it again [ __ ] cvs in their long
ass receipts you people oh dude but yo
we went to cvs the other day tell me why
we got a 35 off coupon any item up to
100
big money savings that's cool but also
they're like yo take these 62 pages one
page has 10 of them i mean yeah they
they're definitely [ __ ] the
environment for real like everyone's
trying to come back on receipts and do
digital [ __ ] they're just like yo you
want like longer ones you know like
eight pages we're leaning into this
[ __ ] receipt length yeah bro they're
[ __ ] tripping uh-huh i want an
itinerary on you you want to take it on
your receipt
i've gotten a receipt so long i've been
upset uh it's a contract [ __ ] cvs giving
me the raw medicine you can eat it cvs
are champions in that category i mean
they they love a long receipt they love
a long receipt
we leaned into it so much [ __ ] cvs
that's all walgreen's better walgreens
is true this is scarce out here really
yeah walgreens is so supreme bro
i see a lot of clips of people stealing
from those out here a lot of what clips
are people stealing from those out here
like online all day yeah that's crazy
didn't they decriminalize like isn't
there a catch-and-release thing for like
right now it's so stupid that's [ __ ]
bro this just reminded me do you have
tim hortons in chicago no not that i
know of no yeah i don't know what that
is either that's a what a breakfast
place it is like
like you think and you think the lines
around in and out are long and starbucks
tim hortons on the
canadian new york areas like the idea
that is not on the west coast is [ __ ]
insane
it's just a coffee shop slash little but
people are [ __ ] addicted to i have a
couple of buddies who live in toronto
and all they talk about is how like oh
you guys don't have tim horton's like oh
tim hortons is so good bro [ __ ] off dude
it's not that it's so good it's just
that they're it's just like an addiction
i mean that's how i am starbucks
sometimes bro i'll be getting starbucks
every chance i get i'll [ __ ] with coffee
i need one of those nitro cold brews
dude
i love coffee i cut myself off to a lot
of fun i don't like coffee with tea
why not tea
i'll chug it if it's good for you he's
good i hate it some nice green teas yes
oh green tea is that dude green tea is
is oh
no sugar to me you're so insane for that
dookie it's healthy though so if you
like in the morning i'll drink it i'll
just chug it i'm saying like i don't
like it i don't drink it though
that's not
that's coffee won't drink at all
that's so nuts you know i don't know if
i could smoke weed in the morning
without coffee it like really balances
it out yeah
dude i bought a keurig and i put it like
uh right next to my computer so in the
morning i just pop a little cake up in
and smoke some weed take some dances
you're man you're part of the club let's
go dude i'm [ __ ] i'm living good with
that [ __ ] i got all the different k-cups
stacked up under the table it's on it's
like a b12
[ __ ] yeah i got them all dude that's
it that's how you kick on the old brain
i mean i don't i don't really like the
starbucks k-cups though i like the foam
ones i'm so awesome what you guys doing
yeah yeah no i feel like [ __ ] hunter
has thompson in the morning i get the
coffee going i got the [ __ ] weed
going yeah you know like
that's about it but i still feel like
that's about it
dude coffee is a great way to start the
day but like once you start it's so hard
to stop i don't like it i just don't
like it i wish i did because i i used to
do a lot of road trips i love coffee i
love so i i just support it i just
support it i am such a like a like a
outright supporter people try to tell me
like coffee is like not a form of
getting water i'm like what the [ __ ] do
you think it is it's just it's not the
but how is it not you're taking water
you're dripping it over some ground
beans it's like stop and i'm telling you
if you only drink coffee you never drink
water you'd be kind of healthy
you're looking at it
i don't agree no usually water i mean
not like i drink coffee think about it i
mean you pour some milk on the cereal
it's still milk
that's a whole different thing you gotta
have water
drink some water with the coffee then
you're chilling this whole drinks water
of course i know he drinks water i'm not
saying he doesn't drink water
i'm just saying hey have a little glass
of water on the side of the coffee then
you got some options once you finish but
she was acting like it's like reverse
hydration or some [ __ ] drinking [ __ ]
coffee like no it is it's acidic
probably this counts towards water
drinking on the daily i don't know if
that counts but i gotcha
that's like saying i drink a seven up
you think they just made it all sugar no
that's water mixed with stuff it's like
chocolate milk is milk there you go i
stopped buying soda at my house good i
don't keep it out of your house
dude hey it got more expensive with this
coved [ __ ] bro inflation is slapping
it's going crazy
i i used to for a while i'd buy the the
like great value brand soda
yeah it's just like [ __ ]
what's your top three i can't say soda
pops though
okay would you say pops
i physically can't say soda why that's
all you just said it right now like in
the context of knowing what i'm talking
it goes against the grain in my brain
you know what's funny i will not say
[ __ ] pop no i i'll never call it a
problem i'm not that [ __ ] yeah
but i feel like a fraud saying soda like
why could you only say pop over there
yeah [ __ ] saying pop pop is such a like
an underwhelming word
soda is the word in oregon you don't say
soda
it's called a pop yeah exactly when i
moved to oregon i went
shut the [ __ ] up
just say [ __ ] soda
or don't criticize me when you mean pop
no i meant soda [ __ ] does it say pop on
the thing no it says [ __ ] coca-cola
so we're both wrong [ __ ] you
oh and then my dad said pop once and i
went it's growing on you that'd make me
so mad we've lived here for two months
one of those things i know pop is not
the right word it's not
it's not it's soda pop we just took the
[ __ ] top off you can sure i mean
whatever if you want to call it soda pop
called soda pop that's so extra though
if you say soda pop you're [ __ ] 70.
yeah yeah of course yeah that is like
might hang me my grandmother likes luddy
you got a snotty handkerchief in your
pocket
you say pop
no i say soda yeah you say you can't
physically say soda i tried saying soda
in life here in california for a couple
years and felt like a [ __ ] fraud so
i'm just would be the same thing if i
went there and started saying pop so i'm
just getting my truth here on the show i
understand
but i've never heard you say poppy you
know that right you've always said yeah
i avoided it yeah
maybe
for so long i'm joking but i know it's
trashy to [ __ ] call it pop it's not
trashy
it's just what people say and oregon
people say that too
that's a little trash it's on the west
coast there's no little spots in the
[ __ ] country soda is the more
sophisticated word i think so i could be
wrong oh i thought that was like the
east coast thing then yeah no it's like
saying like use ain't it
i say use when i'm talking [ __ ] to
people yeah use a [ __ ]
i'm talking about a normal conversation
that's i'll judge a [ __ ] if you
use use juice guys
i'll judge
dr pepper is the supreme soda i'm just
going to say that yeah where we're going
yeah top three okay thank you dr pepper
okay number one okay 100 number two
oh that's so tough
i mean okay
i got respect for those like citrus
sodas you know like like uh sprite and
seven up and all those guys
but they're not worthy of number two
they're not
i'm also going to come out and say that
mountain dew is not worthy of number two
um
root beer
is a a certified number two
personally
i like mug nice
root beer is valid
i think barks is like grandpa root beer
and a w is trash
did you guys have birch beer as a kid
was that a thing i think that's some
off-brand bootleg [ __ ] yeah i don't
think i've ever heard of that okay your
okay all right it's actually not a thing
with caramel in it
oh [ __ ] okay that's a well thought out
so then we set number number two is root
beer mug root beer number three
so what'd you say number one dr pepper
dr pepper of course okay that's i mean
it's obviously the best soda then he
shouted out sprite and squirt and all
those other ones no squirt sucks he'll
try
yeah but that's no it's like a gross
citrus it's like a fruit like a like a
um you know side of the curb rainwater
citrus like
no squirt is gross
um
number three
oh
[ __ ]
this is tough
this is really hard actually no the fans
are gonna like this oh i know i'm just
saying that i think i'm gonna throw
oh [ __ ] man
mountain dew is so valid okay you just
said it's not yeah not for number two
spot we we're on number three now
number three mountain dew is valid
honorary mention to sprite okay
as a 12 year old boy i can't not think
about a lowered sperm count when i hear
mountain dew still
they really i don't know i might have
been too young for that i i remember
that that never fazed me i don't want to
have kids bad branding i know that's
what i thought too like that that's a
bad thing i was like yeah i was like
[ __ ] yeah
even though it's our podcast i i have a
i have a joke about mexican girls
when you just said 12 year old boy and i
told you the joke the other day i can't
say it on here oh no because it just
reminds me of growing up
it's too offensive it's not too
offensive i just don't want youtube to
go uh-huh
you said something you're going to put
up a comedy album under a pseudonym
character because you know what joke i'm
talking about yeah yeah
the punch slot right
gold
dude you get really sponsorship but gold
you gotta get sponsorship from this
water company oh yeah a [ __ ] i have the
machines i have the machines here i have
the machine in my house too
and those little houses
where's the bottle dad i don't know i
don't want to look because if it's
something stupid i'm like why does it
taste so good i'm good i'm gonna do it
for you here we go it's gonna piss us
off because we don't have a deal from
them hold on source garland county
arkansas or kansas okay arkansas you
don't normally hear that attached to
your water it's true what is what's in
garland county do they have like a nice
little spring place i have no idea i
mean the water banks i mean this is
crazy water yeah um
so that's your sodas i don't know why
the [ __ ] we're talking about that what
are your sodas
i don't condone soda these are
recovering at us
okay all right i'm a recovering addict
and i went for four and a half years
and then uncle john passed away and i
was like i'm gonna drink a coke from
uncle john's oh you were in the coke
you're like no it's my uncle johnson and
i drank it went
and referred it back to all the years i
was chugging soda i drink a soda
uh it's i've been drinking soda for on
and off for about 18 months oh no [ __ ]
that's my stomach's been hurting a lot
again so i directly connect this damn i
and i
hate soda okay i will drink soda and not
eat
that's me as a kid if i have three if i
have a dark soda that's like eating
it's like a dark soda
i'll drink three [ __ ] sodas i'll run
around i'm gonna eat light sodas in a
day dark sodas for dinner
i swear to god i don't give a [ __ ] i'll
drink a whole oh my god if there's ice
now i don't have to eat anything you
remember back in the day your aunt or
somebody might have had one of those
official like coca-cola cups did you
ever remember those put some ice that
[ __ ] you felt [ __ ] rich
that was a rich thing yeah i got you we
had the cups the mugs that you go like
this and go why is there water stuck in
it like oh that's just the design oh
there's stars in it
that's the cubs that's sick
wow that's the 90s
that's the [ __ ] we had fill those up
with [ __ ] nice
no [ __ ] soda it's bad for you don't you
upset a hundred percent because the guy
that owns pepsi doesn't drink pepsi
don't drink soda at home only drink it
when you're out doesn't drink dr pepper
because he goes
liquid cigarettes liquid cigs for your
insides that's the way to put it it's so
[ __ ] bad for you
but if we're just going off the top and
saying one of your favorite sodas yeah
of course
of course is bad for you but i mean you
ready
the best orange soda i've ever had we're
gonna come in at number three the best
soda i ever had
i had an orange tree at the push tree's
house and i got the tree and i i got a
couple pieces of orange okay and i put
them in my [ __ ] cup i put ice in it
and i poured orange soda i don't even
know what orange soda was okay oh my god
when you eat those pieces of orange at
the end they're like eating the orange
sliced candies from the clear bag
they like become carbonated a little bit
it's [ __ ] weird
third coolest soda ever
number two you hate squirt i hate it
ruby red squirt
on a whole nother level yeah it's up
there i love ruby red squirt so much
okay and chug that [ __ ] in abundance
kick i don't know something about going
oh what is it is that a flavor of it
ruby red squirts i've never seen squirt
i don't know if i've ever had it no it
sucks i hate squirting i i hate default
squirts as well i hate it i hate it
because i have a story behind it of why
i hate squirt i'll tell you that okay
and we'll get in there
i need to find a kid that looks like me
when i was younger i do all these
reenactors
um
and then number one i gotta be honest
man
ice
and a cherry
coke
cherry coke is valid honestly i i think
cherry coke is okay because you can eat
it the icicle i ate some cherries that's
how i thought as a kid man but you know
what she needs a
i would chug it at my grandma's all the
time dude cherry coke is very good i i
respect that pick honestly i like it
better than default coke for sure
because coke is good you get both
a little bit of cherry in this coke all
right i'm not super big on regular coke
but it's okay cherries when they started
putting lip why are we all talking about
soda for 20. can you tell the difference
between pepsi and coke though
yeah what okay that's not a million
percent spokes way better than tj pepsi
and coke
i will say slapped on soda mellow yellow
bomb
fantastic cooler
i'm gonna throw out
passionate thought here
okay
i'm a ginger ale drinker here okay all
right really start here is that when we
got the [ __ ] mini fridge i
stocked that [ __ ] full of [ __ ]
canada to dry first thing really rosy
drinks i don't like it
i don't know why i don't even really my
grandmother drank it it's nothing
because he loves it she eats it all the
time okay but now i've come to find out
no ginger and [ __ ] ginger ale no it's
just a soda
you thought there was ginger in it well
that would be honestly i thought
it too i just i just figured there has
to be a
optional it's a goddamn ginger ale bro
oh the only thing i ever drink in my
life was the first time i went to vegas
and i was mixing with jack daniels honey
no no just jack daniels
and drinking that and mixing it and
drinking that somewhere out there
because i don't have the phone anymore
somewhere out there has a 21 year old me
i put my phone cause leo was sharing a
room and he went home early so i had the
vegas night by myself after we all
[ __ ] up i had a fifth and i had hella
canada dry i've never tried
i tried to go oh i'll mix it
and i have a put my phone at the end of
the bed or at the end of the room guys
somebody has this somewhere so that's me
if you have this phone this is me please
give it to me give it back and it's me
jumping from bed to bed kicking off the
wall doing flips coming back because i
set up a shot right in front of the
camera
and i took a shot and i run back i was
doing i did that for 40 minutes guys
because going crazy and i was running
off the walls just jumping [ __ ] i drank
the whole bottle damn i mean it was like
you stayed here when i had it
but i woke up in the morning [ __ ] shh
faced
and i had that video so somebody out
there that's me yeah that was a lot
thinner do you get bad hangovers i don't
really drink that much anymore but no
really
no i get it i've got a couple hangovers
i'm like bedridden when i get when i was
doing mad rails though
because i would drink another fifth
because i was like whoa
and then wake up drinking and and doing
coke is the most dangerous combo it's
like a alcohol it's so bad it's a it's a
anti-alcohol drunk but when it wears off
it hits you at once well and it's also
it's it's really like dangerous actually
to do like for your heart of course like
it's so bad
yeah it's so bad for you what the [ __ ] i
used to do it all the time me too
terribles are doing it right now
watching this don't do it yeah cut that
[ __ ] out no doing cocaine watching the
[ __ ] podcast no more no more dude the
reason i love it
the reason i don't have a discord server
anymore is because kids would get on
webcam and just do hard ass drugs
together all day and i was like i don't
want to be responsible for that [ __ ] you
know
no you can't be
that sucks i never considered that
people doing [ __ ] people actual drugs
wasn't like smoking math and [ __ ] bro
like people were weird doing hard [ __ ]
it was never just like a like a weed
kind of thing um
i don't know i'm just busy making
content i don't want to manage a discord
server and all that yeah also remember
when we got back on track and we didn't
talk about soda for 20 years yeah kinda
not really
holy [ __ ] are you ready for the next
question sure yeah what the [ __ ]
what's going on oh my god
sorry
i'm sorry but those 40 minutes flew by
for you guys driving all right let's
just say that's what we're here for
we're here for okay ready when is the
first time you ever caught high or doing
drugs by your mom first time by your mom
by my mom
oh
so
it wasn't necessarily as surprising to
her because i had been caught first by
my dad
and he told her about it so
yeah it was weed um my dad so he came
home one time
and i had a smile on your face
that's from tobacco on a plate and he
came home and his dumbass thought that
was weed because he never smoked with
you before
yeah
both my parents are
like dutch guts
yeah yeah it was like swisher got on a
plate and he's like is that weed so he
called me and he like asked me to come
home so i came home and he's like so is
this weed and i was like that's tobacco
and he like didn't believe me and i was
like yes tobacco and uh he went and like
searched my room
and like found some weed that i had
that's tobacco that's weed and sweet
that out [ __ ] idiot jesus is gross
that
yeah no my dad's [ __ ] i'm colorblind
dad you know he's colorblind what kind
of dad are you doing
he he pulled that out and then he told
my mom so then my mom uh she would
search my room quite a lot and the thing
with her is
she would find stuff and not necessarily
like confront me at first she would a
lot but like if i was at school let's
say and she searched my room and found
something or searched the house and
found something i'd hidden um she
wouldn't necessarily confront me on it
immediately she would take it and i'd
find out and then like three days later
she'd come home pissed as [ __ ] and just
like
get mad about it you know like she was
she was like calculated with it almost
you know um
i'd get kicked out a lot for the [ __ ]
i'd do you know forced to stay at like
friends houses and stuff um
and by that point
when my mom started finding stuff i
didn't really have a relationship with
my dad
so
you stopped chilling with your dad
yeah
yeah uh i haven't seen him in like
probably like five six years yeah you
said
yeah total dick but um
either way i um
i got caught early on just with weed but
i'd say the first time i got caught
with hard drugs that i can remember at
least
um
i um so i had some acid
in my uh my room and i had this little
like
photo book from when i was a kid of like
little like pictures of me right um and
i put like a couple tabs of acid and
some tin foil in there
and my mom would go through my room all
the time and she found it
she went through the pictures dude she
was like a fed with it she was in depth
she knew the glove running it along the
[ __ ] lining of the bed like a [ __ ]
guard but like also her finding myself
is a very common thing like i would have
to get super creative with where i'd
hide stuff because outside like in the
bush is always the best place i know and
i i would always try to avoid the
outside spot because i wanted my weed to
stay like
safe in a jar
i didn't have jars
i spent all my money on weed
[ __ ] that i had no money for anything
else
correct yeah oh always are you kidding
me stolen from the kitchen yeah i'm not
buying those but keep it in the bush in
the middle where it's like it's floating
i never i'm not spending money on jars
bro i would never ride around with more
than like 20 40 on me unless i had just
finished selling like maybe half of the
ounce i just bought you know yeah
buy some more you know
but
so you got caught with the asses your
mom found it
yeah um when i went to rehab i had some
acid uh this isn't with my mom but i had
some acid that i left in my dad's house
in a mini fridge in the freezer and i
never found out if he found it or not
he ever confronted you after i went to
rehab i never i like i stopped talking
to my dad i never like i haven't been to
that house or like seen him since then
damn he just had a horrible trip yeah
imagine he pulled it out
and just like started that's why you
haven't talked to him you think he's mad
at you no he's just no that's not why i
haven't talked to him but like
i always wondered i was sitting there
and i was like [ __ ] man wait you haven't
talked to this person at all not really
no i spoke to him like once like
a couple months ago and then before that
had been like five years weird is he it
kind of
or what the [ __ ] um
he's just kind of an [ __ ] i'm saying
he never reached out like yo you're not
coming over for christmas [ __ ]
no no
dude so part of the reason i stopped
talking to is because my grandpa on his
side died right he didn't tell me until
like two months after he died
he was just like oh yeah grandpa's dead
by the way
months later yeah
no funeral no funeral like he'd been
dead
he just texted me and he's like yeah
gpa's gone and i was like shut the [ __ ]
up
no no no not literally like that's just
say bros
[Laughter]
with sad eyes
this episode has a theme yeah
yeah don't tell mom the babysitter is
dead don't let goblins say you're dying
yeah
yeah
if anyone leaves hate comments i'm just
going to say they're dying oh no
youtube i'm sorry
i'm kidding i'm kidding spotify is cool
though spotify cool thumbs up good on
spotify youtube you're [ __ ] up by the
way youtube if you're watching this
spotify is partnered with us maybe you
just give us some slack [ __ ] you yeah
they should just give me these customers
um putting a little pressure on you it's
all good
exactly
so
he told you two months later yeah and
that's when you guys kind of stopped
talking uh for good yeah like for a
while why because you're like
dick yeah
yeah i was i was pit i was like are you
serious dude
i didn't even know
is that just how he is though or is he
trying to like be a dick and doing that
he's definitely trying to be a dick and
he didn't tell you your grandpa died
because he was trying to be a dick to
you yes your dad's an [ __ ] i hope you
guys watch this you're a [ __ ] jerk
what does he do for work isn't he like a
salesman no he works at a law firm
paralegal he's not a lawyer but he's
like under that he does like paperwork
stuff oh okay yeah
what a dick yeah
and when your mom and dad got divorced
is because one of them's a dick are they
both just [ __ ] um
what cause my dad's a dick definitely
okay okay yeah he i mean he was like
super like mean like he he would raise
his voice a lot like he was like
super out of pocket my mom was more like
chill she was just tricked with me
because she didn't want you to end up
like your dad yeah and be a [ __ ] jerk
she turned out to be just a really nice
dude she doesn't like drugs do you
assume that he realizes that you're
doing well now like does he see you
online
yeah that's not a tweet you can share it
you can share it
it's funny you already tweeted it like
it's [ __ ] well when i spoke to him
recently yeah that's pretty funny when i
when i ordered him some [ __ ] wait did i
tell you about it i didn't tell you
about that on stream no oh sorry i
talked about this when i was drunk on
the stream um so so after that all
happened right hold on tell him tell him
it's funny
no i just i just tweeted him some some
statistic not tweet him i i sent him
some statistics you know
send it on twitter
it's all it needs to be said
go follow me on twitter that's awesome
okay there's a good way to do it boom
what is it though on twitter um what my
handle yeah the goblin with three ends
oh it's right three ends on the end and
then um i could get them the one with
one end or two the guy yeah there's two
guys holding out both the names and the
guy with just the name goblin yeah
holding out hard
like i'd pay him he doesn't care we
talked about that today right yeah we
just talked about that
i don't know this room has no time
there's no sun
yeah it's like a like a chamber it is
dude
but um
what's it called uh
i so the [ __ ] with him i um i ordered
him like a shed
delivered to his house because i was
just like he's gonna have to move it and
that's so funny
i did not expect you to say that
like a pre-built one
they just jumped it off yeah they just
dumped it they dropped it they sent a
picture
it was built yeah it's like a pre-built
it was in a box it was huge bro like i
swear to god one of the biggest boxes
i've ever [ __ ] seen in my life like
you can't even put it in your garage did
you say who it was from
i just put his name on it it's from like
whatever company
it's just like you just got a [ __ ]
stone like a huge amount of [ __ ]
from nick
he probably knew who no he doesn't know
he says it's more than just a shed he
knows no
you didn't say that to me well i just
started off with the [ __ ]
what else did you send a pallet of water
like the cases
but that never showed up but i ordered
another lighter pallet of water yeah i
got a pallet of water i got two sheds
one that was lighter i found them cheap
discount
and then i ordered like a desk like a
pre-built desk that was like made out of
wood this is really heavy
what
this is an interesting way to troll a
guy yeah
it was really cheap it was all cheap
just to like [ __ ] with him dude i don't
know like one day i was really drunk and
i was like yeah this would be super
funny
because like he said some [ __ ] to my mom
too like he had spoken to her and i was
like kind of pissed and i was like yo
dude
just [ __ ] with him you know like
obviously
yeah yeah
to make an outside office
dude the guy has a bad back
you're an [ __ ] he's gonna have to
hire someone to get to live in like a
neighborhood just like a regular yeah
just a regular assignment i was smashing
the gun
did you go looking for a shed or were
you just like looking i just looked for
a cheap one it's like really cheap
everything built
the one there
the one the one of them
one of them they put a picture the other
one they didn't put a picture and they
delivered it so i don't know but they
said pre-built like they were advertised
pre-built
so it's such an odd thing
i got them cheap
you know what she should have sent
next time send a bunch of cheap flowers
and let them leave them on the lawn or
in the front porch so you have to pick
up each individual thing or sweep and
sweeping hurts your back so bad yeah but
like
you feel bad down there
sweeping or moving a shed you hire
somebody buy free [ __ ] take it off my
property it's easier than either way
that's funny
yeah it was a funny way i don't know
dude he's done some very [ __ ] up [ __ ]
upside
of water i was like the palette never
came bro i had to get a refund
but the fact that you thought was gonna
be shitty to move oh water cases oh
you're right yeah that would suck that
was sucks especially when they start
falling off the side of the yeah then
you got a whole problem she's rolling
into the street exactly you thought this
through yeah
oh my god these are the things that
frustrates you the most when you're
moving you really can't get in trouble
for shipping a shed to a guy no dude i
paid for it no you bought it
it's a gift yeah you're a good son
you're welcome
if you wanted a shed now it's your
chance
oh my god i love it
yeah that was a fun little like activity
oh my god we're talking about getting a
shot that's even [ __ ] funnier to me
guys
dude i got like a super cheap one not a
nice one it was like a couple hundred
bucks type [ __ ] like
made out of garbage material like awful
you got to get like a [ __ ] forklift
to put it in your backyard if you
actually want to use it
yep
yep i love the thought process on this
revenge
that's some cutting [ __ ] yeah yeah oh
yeah petty in the best way though like
that's funny yeah i i felt it was pretty
innovative control other people like
this or no
no it's just i mean i haven't really
done something like that before my dad
or anything it's just like he's gonna be
an [ __ ] and i was like yeah put the
[ __ ] in
thing
i don't know what i was just [ __ ] up
and i thought of it one day and i was
like that's really funny what would be
the thing that i would send somebody
you'd be i could see you doing some
extra i like the shed sound it's like
swatting somebody you're shedding
somebody yeah like it's not really
harmful it's just like you gotta shut it
down driveway
yeah like if you really
yeah send them mad packages of tiles
bags of
concrete oh
concrete's good
concrete's good
you can probably get bags of dirt for
cheap too
you're like 50 bags of dirt [ __ ] yeah
you're doing some landscaping [ __ ] oh
my god i'm just trying to think of
that's the funniest [ __ ] i've ever heard
you said a machete because you know he
has to move it also he has a bad back
and he lives in a neighborhood
and then the fact that the waters i'm
thinking they're going to fall out
they're going to fall out i'm going to
get back this is the worst position due
to old [ __ ] that's snowing there's ice
involved yeah yeah
amazing i can't believe that turned into
that oh yeah that's she got to do all
that of it as she was love it that's a
good one are you ready for my next one
yep let's see it yep i am i'm [ __ ]
baked dude
i'm baked um
what's your most memorable running from
the cop story
oh
that's a good question um i mean i've
been to parties where i've had to run
from cops
um
i think i i got caught a lot honestly
i have more stories getting caught than
i do necessarily running and getting
away you know like i've only been to a
few parties where i've actually ran it's
because there were so many people
obviously not gonna arrest everybody but
like um obviously it's not like cop lit
me up and i drove away you know or some
[ __ ] like that uh um
i'm not a very fast runner so
i i typically don't really run from the
cops i just kind of uh embrace the fact
that i'm white and take what i got to
take you know embrace the fact that i'm
white go
hello sir hi sir my mom psychiatric drug
counselor
the local drug dealers attacked me and
got me high on weed you know like leave
me alone
drug dealers attacked me with weeds call
an
ambulance here's my mom's car
i call her um
but
i guess can i modify that into getting
caught
because i like i don't necessarily think
and any all the experiences just your
typical like jumping a fence at a party
type [ __ ] you know it's not like some
cop was like right on my ass about a
[ __ ] tase me and i got away you know
that boy would have got my ass i'll tell
you that
yeah no i was i wasn't pulling some like
nfl street [ __ ]
but um
i miss that game dude can they remaster
it yo you know what's crazy we had ricky
williams on here oh he's the
[ __ ] i used to use an nfl street
a lot oh that's so good deadly spins
that's so sick
um i was just thinking about that but
getting caught i remember so
i think i i told you about this before
potentially but um you remember when i
told you about that like uh ashton like
getting rob thing the whole like revenge
story
so um we went and [ __ ] up the guy's
house we had all the stuff in the car
still like a day or two later
and we were smoking in this parking lot
and there was like a
trespassing after so-and-so time time
that we missed
i had to get that down so
uh the this cop pulled in
and shined a spotlight at us and we had
in our trunk a two by four ski mask for
all of us like
different like
an axe like a hatchet in the car
a bunch of [ __ ] up [ __ ] like a
2x4 had like a nail sticking out of it
like a little blood on it
because you [ __ ] up uh the car or
whatever right why do you have it then
because my friend caught his hand on the
car window
so he was like freaking out about that
but we also had weed which at the time
was still legal in illinois um he had
some other girls purse because she
forgot it in the car oh my god and it
had the weed in it we didn't know we had
weed but we also had like uh acid and
like
uh my friend ashton had some ketamine
and [ __ ] in the glove box like some
synthetic [ __ ] he had he had so much
[ __ ] so when the cop pulled up he dumped
it in the mcdonald's cups we had because
it was it was pretty much all powder
besides the acid so it would dissolve
you dropped the acid tabs in like one of
the other cups right
we only they searched the whole car like
five cops pulled up and
they like they were laughing at us
because our friend kyle in the back seat
was so cute out that he couldn't write
his own name or anything um he
they were giving us tickets for the weed
and they were still searching the car as
they were writing these to us right um
so we were still freaking the [ __ ] out
and at one point while they were
searching it they left us alone on the
curb and we were talking about who's
taking what tickets and like ashton was
like yo dude i'll take the acid charge
you take the k charge like we'll we'll
split all this because we all had
different drugs so we were like yeah
we're all going to get charged if we
don't just like say i had this you had
this you know um so we're like divvying
up charges and [ __ ] and he's on
probation he's like yo i'm going to jail
for a long time um and i was i was like
yo dude i'll like i'll take this charge
you know trying to like divvy him up and
[ __ ] they didn't find any [ __ ] we put in
the cups because it had dissolved
luckily um i don't know how they didn't
find the yet they might not have even
looked in the cups but what was really
weird is the cups were gone
like like empty like there was nothing
in them we put acid in one
ashton to be fair i wasn't the one who
put the acid in it you think the cop
drank it no i don't think he drank it
but i don't know what happened with it
maybe maybe he just thought it was a
piece of paper in there and didn't think
[ __ ] of it or like dumped it out i don't
know what happened they weren't like
they didn't have art on them they were
just pink like pink pieces of paper so
they didn't necessarily look like you
know the craziest acid tabs if you
didn't know you know the perfect size
and shape of acid tabs you might not
recognize them as tabs you know um
they just kind of look like construction
paper almost but they were definitely
some strong tabs so
he uh
he ashton claimed he put them in the cup
but like
looking back at it i don't actually know
what happened and how he didn't get
caught because we only got away with
tickets for the weed that was in that
girl's purse she left her purse in the
car with the uh the weed and she had a
pipe in there they didn't get mad about
the
they pulled out the mask they pulled up
the two by four put it on top of the car
they took our cigarettes we're all under
age put them on top of the car they took
all of our [ __ ] they took the weed the
bowl the girls prayers put on top of the
car
they didn't even ask what we were up to
with the [ __ ] that they found in the
trunk like they didn't say [ __ ] they
didn't care
so all they cared about was the weed
they found and they just gave us a
ticket and our friend kyle was so cait
up that when they tried to make him sign
his name on the ticket he just wrote
like a really long squiggle line and
then when he tried to give the pen back
to the cop he like could couldn't move
his arm the right way and threw the pen
like at the other guy's car like he
threw it so hard to hit the other cops
car
and he was like oh whoa buddy and they
let us drive away what the [ __ ] yeah
we drove home that night
with ski masks in the car with a [ __ ]
arrest is all you right there in there
yeah no no no no no someone else's purse
like you robbed this girl and hit
the nail in it
yeah looking at it i i've honestly never
thought about it like that i always just
thought about it no i've always thought
about it for the way like i know why
it's there we
smashed it we brutalized some guy's car
but that was a different day we didn't
rob them
but like yeah when you look at it like
that you're totally right it does look
like we like beat some woman with a 2x4
and took her purse you know
that's yeah i never thought about that
and you got to go home
yeah and they let us take the [ __ ]
what we took the not the weed and the
pipe but we took like our cigarettes
back even they didn't even take them
[Music]
what
town is this
this is aurora illinois
aurora where they do wayne's world
isn't that it
i think
it's a it's a pretty nice area it's i
mean it's not about it yeah the city was
everybody in this car
why all yes cops
mostly fat white guys
old bald
sounds about right hmm
it was not trying to figure out like
what kind of parking lot were you in
it was a parking lot to some little like
um
you know those little like one-story
buildings like a bunch of like
chiropractors in them those little
businesses one of those kind of parking
lots
i'm just trying to process like how you
didn't you you even feel lucky yeah yeah
it's insane that we didn't get caught
with it we should have gone to should
have been to jail immediately yes we
should have like we should have gotten
charged with some serious [ __ ] because
we had some serious [ __ ]
what the [ __ ]
yep love it
so that was the best getting caught
all right we didn't have to do the
getting running they're running for the
cops because that's fine i've only ran
from cops like five times since yeah i
mean i i haven't done it too much i
haven't really had an encounter with a
cop in quite a while actually
same question it's been a long time
question
you're stopped with your friend at a
stop at a he gets pulled over
he's like yo i'm about to [ __ ] take
off
would it take you one second or three
seconds to jump out that [ __ ] car and
roll out roll the ground or would you go
with him i don't know all right martial
it's time i'm in the car and i go i'm
gonna [ __ ] do yeah i'm dipping out
real quick getting out of the car right
yeah
yeah yeah
i might i might take him out first
take one out the dude driving maybe grab
the keys or something yeah i'm going to
disable him if he's going all cycle on
me no no yeah putting you in the car for
that is [ __ ] up i'm saying we're
pulled over like you i'ma take off
you can get out now oh i got you yeah
all right never mind yeah yeah yeah i'm
gonna disable him damn marty if i'm
running for the cops i gotta worry about
marty
yeah
you got a gun i'm not going with
you don't have a gun maybe
[Music]
like i might be fine at the end but if
you have a gun i'm not getting shot with
you i'm not doing that but like you know
you get shot anyway just driving away
true yeah if you drive towards an
officer yeah you're right anything
[ __ ] are wild out here i i
expect cops to just start lighting i
don't think about that and they're going
to pull up constantly and then you see
these like high speed chases that go on
at like 30 miles an hour for [ __ ]
ever it's just i don't know well a lot
of them get called off for like public
safety and [ __ ] but like they have your
plate by then they'll just go to your
house
yeah
okay so i don't know why i got that
question but i just had that in my like
i've been in that situation before where
it's like damn i really need a ride to
work my homeboy's [ __ ] cousin is
willing to take me but if we get pulled
i know he's [ __ ] taken off i'm
calling off work
i feel you
it's not worth it yeah [ __ ] yeah um
all right so this one know where your
head was at you say no gun maybe he says
maybe
no defense there's no situation where
i'm like let's go
i mean yeah obviously i'm probably
getting out but
you never if i'm a little [ __ ] up hey
oh no
two beers i'm running from the cops
i'm not saying i'm the one running and
i'll sit in the car and give miller let
them run i'll just be a shotgun i have
my hands up like yo it wasn't me
i'll be doing this whole time out the
window i'm not that [ __ ] like [ __ ]
doing
[ __ ] i'll throw up hell is [ __ ] out
the window
what's i love cops in sign language
i'll be doing that over and over like
he's throwing up gang signs and running
away from us shoot it
[ __ ] okay let's get on to the next thing
i was gonna ask what the [ __ ] just
happened
why did i ask that question i just had
an idea like
yeah no there's no situation where i see
myself going i'm gonna stay with you bro
let's do it have to be some john q [ __ ]
where they don't understand
some crazy [ __ ] like that that's
different
i'm just talking about like yo
you just don't want to get dui
take the bus
take the dui stupid here we go my next
one all right let's get it i see you do
these a lot yeah it's called drug
tearless oh yeah so i saw one that you
had 20 22. just uploaded it so explain
that to me
so
i kind of made it an annual thing on my
channel but i like to rank each drug you
know you've seen have you ever seen
those tier list videos where
really have you ever seen these marty
just on your channel okay so exactly
yeah i mean yeah
have you watched them on my channel i
just seen this one okay but it was not
this year's it was a previous one so i
just every year rank the different drugs
that are kind of like mainstream drugs
that a lot of people do uh because i
feel like
it's kind of fun eh uh the last video
got like two and a half million views so
i was like yeah you know i gotta i gotta
do another one but also i feel like it's
a good way for me to kind of update
people on what drugs i'm actually like
doing and [ __ ] you know for example last
year cocaine was ranked really high for
me because i was a goddamn feed um this
year i haven't done blow in like
probably eight or nine months now you
know so uh it's ranked very differently
now this year um
i feel like it's a good way for like
people who
that don't necessarily want to go watch
one of my like 400 videos on my channel
uh can
get a gist of like what's going on you
know yeah like it's a fun video to make
too honestly so what's this year's tier
uh like each one no no i mean like
just give us a little piece
so
i put i can go watch the rest so i
separate like flour from concentrates i
i kind of differentiate between the
different ways to get stoned because i
feel like they're very different like
edibles for example i put in i think
like
i don't remember if it was maybe beetier
this year because i don't do edibles
that much um
concentrates i put an s to here because
i've been dabbing
uh a very long time i dab all day every
day uh i like you know i like doing it
like that um and then flower i put oh
it was either like top of a
or like this got a [ __ ]
system there's a group dude there's a
big system going on here man this is big
[ __ ] this is a big event at this point i
mean this is serious colleges are going
to be referring to this chart yeah this
is no this is serious news college is
gonna come in and be like you need to
look at this and study this they're
gonna have classes on this um and uh
cause you do one on the best drugs to
sell also yeah
i did i did do one on that [ __ ]
are you monetized
i um this is insane that you get they
they're like
no it's fine i i might i think that
video when i when i purge so my channel
might go so
but the fact that it stays up yeah it is
mind-blowing it's a good video it's a
good video
it follows youtube rules i mean i'm not
encouraging it's it's
you know
he's just mind blown because our [ __ ]
billboard video got age restricted
really your billboard video got
age-restricted yeah wouldn't even show
that's so stupid we don't even do
anything in the video that's something
billboards could put up
you mean
so you didn't even like smoke [ __ ] we
hit the bomb [ __ ] was some [ __ ] was
blurry you couldn't see no balls within
like two montages youtube is so petty
with that like if you go on camera and
smoke anything at any point you exhale
anything you're done
you're done but it says yeah that's just
youtube dude yeah it's so bad i hate it
susan you need to change it up come on
do better i hope susan watches this
yeah he's not you put her on blast that
first episode pretty good oh yeah
she ain't never gonna watch this
so speaking of you said cocaine's on a
different tier how does phil being
basically drug-free feels good honestly
it's nice um
it's a lot different than i'm used to i
mean i feel like most of my life i've
gone through phases of doing different
[ __ ]
um and this is the first time in a while
where i'm just getting stoned and drunk
here and there you know like now it's
starting at 11 a.m [ __ ] yeah but i'm not
it's only like three beers deep so
casual drunk but um casual buzz i'd say
but um
no it feels good it's i feel like i'm
able to get a lot more [ __ ] done you
know i feel like i i thought i was a lot
more productive than i was
you know
like i remember i'd be sitting there
doing coke can i be up for like two days
straight and like i got so much [ __ ]
done in reality i just sat there and
played video games for like two days
straight you know [ __ ] did nothing
else like
chain smoked weed spent a bunch of money
you know it's a it's a good feeling
honestly it took a lot of getting used
to like it's not easy
it was very very hard to like
kind of quit doing hard [ __ ] because
it's just like
people don't do drugs because they don't
feel good you know i mean obviously they
feel [ __ ] great
and
i mean if it weren't for weed i don't
think i could have done it
we just most fun he's different dude i
don't think i'm ever gonna stop getting
stoned i'm gonna be like 80 years old
[ __ ] ripped
is the little coke addict voice still
going crazy all the time
you know it's funny you mentioned that
uh
i got this uh this floss and i was
flossing my teeth this morning
and it tasted and smelled like cocaine
oh it's something in uh
in house pain and floss we got and i was
i was sitting there and i was like
i was like i gotta i gotta get some new
floss bro i can't use this [ __ ] there's
like three things i've smelled that
smell like coke
it's got that that chemical
chemicals that hits you right
yes it fills your nose like a noxious
gas like it just thank you yeah
like before we started we were talking
about
uh
what if the cure for zombies was [ __ ]
rails of coke
we could make a coke gun and fun that's
what we're talking about yeah yeah yeah
make coke guns parliament lights me and
my friends yup because if you're a smoke
department light cigarette it has a dip
right in the mouthpiece yeah pack it
with coke
and then light it so the first like 30
seconds of [ __ ] that was just
oh my god
loved it but what if the cure for
zombies was cocaine that would be
[ __ ] sick dude this drop
dude blowing rails
zombies face we have to get my my plug
out of jail
if that was the case yeah zombies let's
just save them don't worry
we'll find another guy
dude
your friend's safer in the cell
i don't know about that you've seen the
movies the jail's the first to go
there's cocaine in jail okay well we'll
free him and get more cocaine outside of
jail i got you sorry youtube i mean but
damn i'm joking um
this is a supposed coke plug not a real
person did we talk about this on camera
already what i could i don't know i
don't know if you are or not i think so
i don't know talk about what if we
talked about that that could have been
like 45 minutes long
the coke
oh that was before we started the
episode yeah yeah the zombie [ __ ] yeah
that's right that's right yeah okay okay
that's before we started before we
started yes yes [ __ ] oh it's okay we got
it on camera now it's documented okay
next question story
i'm just gonna throw some key words out
at you oh [ __ ] okay you tell me this
story oh boy give me some good keywords
barnes and noble ketamine homeless man
dude
dude
my friend
ashton we would look for like fun places
to go to do ketamine right
um
ketamine is is something that he did a
lot and he would let me do for free with
him a lot because he always had so much
of it and barnes and noble i'm telling
you it's a vibe bro you can you could
chill out in there
it's you know you don't have to buy
anything to chill there it's
air-conditioned in the summer
they have comfy chairs it's so big and
they have like two employees at a time
so no one's gonna stop you from nothing
so we would go there
and do ketamine
and there's this homeless guy the barn
like a coffee area right like a like a
starbucks or like you know a place where
you could grab some coffee right yeah
yeah you've been to barnes and noble
yeah yeah i mean it's [ __ ] sick isn't
it yeah it's sick i mean some of them
are a little scuffed like the big ones
the two-story ones yeah those shits are
sick
those are a dying breed now a lot of
those are clothes it's sad honestly but
um a lot of grandma's in there kids dude
everybody's doing drugs
like everybody in a bookstore is [ __ ]
wholesome for the most part yeah
yeah books book short people are
very real with it they're not k-hauling
and and that's the thing too
they're not necessarily looking at you
being like oh that's a tweaker there's a
homeless guy in there and they let him
chill you know so i mean it's not a big
deal but like you know me and ashley
were showing at the table one thing led
to another were you know engaged
conversating with a homeless guy
ashton's a a huge people person so he
he's talking to anyone right he's a very
nice guy he's he's talking to this guy
um
i'm chilling there and i'm so cait up
that i
i assume you've never done it
okay um
have i ever told you like how it feels
yes yeah it's
awesome
it's a slippery slope it is it's like oh
get right here and you're high over here
you're [ __ ] yeah over here and and the
the line where you cross to get to that
that other point is so thin
it's so thin yeah it sounds
i'm so [ __ ] higher i feel like i
would do this and overshoot my shotgun
it happens a lot especially when you
first start doing it it's really easy to
do that do you have a tolerance you
don't know how much you're supposed to
do so it's one of those drugs that like
it's really hard to get into
but this homeless guy
well tweaker man
tweaker man we found out one thing led
to another
ashton from what i recall i'm pretty
sure you gave him some ketamine
in the barns of normal yeah because what
we would do at least is we would go to
the bathroom
and in the bathroom we do the same thing
at school right the strat is you smoke
it no you don't smoke it oh that would
be
oh
i think one of the only drugs
that tastes worse than molly or xanax
it's probably no
ketamine is about as bad as xanax taste
was
but the taste of it if you smoked it
you'd probably puke for like an hour
like it's one of the most vile tasting
things because it just drips down the
back of your throat and your [ __ ] goes
numb and and you just taste this this
garbage eventually you're like your
throat will go numb if you do enough of
it you get a little bit of drip you know
you don't want to gum it because it
tastes awful bomb sorry all that sounded
great to me
sorry i'll do drugs anymore but
i'm gonna drip for an hour and now
there's nothing like perfect no no no
it's it's not like the coke drip it it's
like a more gross tasting like chemical
like
drip you know it's not like oh yay drip
but also you don't feel a lot of it you
don't necessarily realize it because um
your shit's
it's you're tranquilized bro i mean
you're off decay um
but
yeah
yeah ketamine's okay yeah
i'm so [ __ ] i'm i'm feeling great
right now what everybody start the day
bro
what are we hitting
damn it
i do so much [ __ ] after this it's
[ __ ] hilarious
yeah um i feel that
so we were at ketamine homeless man yes
my next story i want to hear from you
let's hear it you ready
it says keywords
caught doing coke by my dad
so if your dad's a square and doesn't
know about weed he knows what coke looks
like because of movies i'm assuming so
the further like the more drugs i
started to do
my dad started like
looking more [ __ ] up online and learning
about it so my dad wasn't as naive as he
was like for long right um and also when
i would go to stay with my dad my mom
would tell him things right so he would
kind of like to an extent have an idea
of [ __ ] but also like my dad uh
he he just didn't really like
i don't know he didn't work the way my
mom did in the sense where like you know
my mom would kick me out a lot my dad
like
he would get mad for like a short period
of time you know my mom would be pissed
me for like a [ __ ] week dude my dad
he'd be mad for like a day and he just
forget about it right
so
when this happened i i got caught doing
a lot of drugs from my dad actually um
both of my parents i wasn't sneaky with
my drug use
i wasn't sneaky with my drug use bro
um so
a lot of times my dad would have a
schedule where he'd supposed to be
working right like let's say he'd go to
work at like 7 a.m because he had to
commute
um
and he didn't get home these are fire i
[ __ ] love the nerds they upped that
flavor but yeah if the flavors up that
would be insane a little bit
give us a second technical difficulties
marty's changing the camera and we're uh
we're hanging out and uh
there's a pineapple shirt under the sea
i'm hitting my eyeball dude you know i
got the shirt at target
[ __ ] target target bro crushing it
what a cop sick yeah [ __ ] yeah it was
like i went there to get some
some like laundry detergent chip this
thing was like 20 bucks
such a cop such a god but no
um are we still doing camera stuff go go
oh okay
so um
when i was younger
i i would occasionally very rarely
um do some coke whether it was like
from ashton and i gotten a little extra
from him because this a lot of times
that i got caught by my dad where prior
to my um have you seen my coat
chronicles series yes i've seen i've
seen part
one i believe okay so that kind of time
frame was summer of 2019 and this took
place like well before that right i
haven't lived with my dad since i went
to rehab so this happened back when i
was in high school so i was like 17
years old 16 years old type [ __ ] i was
still in school
um
you know i might i actually might have
just dropped out no i was definitely
selling school i take that back i was
100 still in school but either way
i had hung out with my buddy ashton once
again a very common denominator in a lot
of these like high school you know drug
stories um he was a cool guy but either
way i had i had hung out with him and i
got a little extra coke whatever drug of
the day he would pull out was just like
boom you know like we're doing that [ __ ]
um
and he'd always be very generous with
like the amounts like you could give him
let's say [ __ ] 20 bucks right
he would give you like a line there but
he also gave you something to go home
with you know like if you were really
friends with him like he's very generous
with it um and we were tight and i'd
drive him around a lot i like the kind
of deal was i drive him to serves and
he'd like
you know hook me up so i had some extra
coke and
at that point i had gone home right and
i was i was chilling at my dad's house
and my dad was never home so i never
really had to worry about much and i had
done some coke uh not too much and the
quality of it looking back was
not the greatest it was good for the
time but i've done better since then my
my current coke man uh free them free
the dude um
free the dude uh not not even because i
want coke from anymore just because i
don't know let the guy out but
oh
it's just the venomogee yes it's just
the kefka it's the
our dopest shop
nice with the raw papers too it's the hh
seaweed it's pretty wild nice we smoking
this [ __ ] yes we smoke it [ __ ] yeah
i like this so wait hi i have a question
about this
how does like
hhc keep work does did you get the same
amount of keef off of like hemp flour
it's hemp flour it's cbd wheat yeah but
like with the then they infuse all it is
is that's all infused with hhc oil okay
that's it
but i'm saying like so the kief is from
hemp flour yes does hemp flour get as
kiffy as like normal flour like i don't
know but
because i wonder how much flour it
actually took to get this to get that
much yeah yeah that's yeah that's one
that's a good one great question
actually i don't know
that's what i'm trying to say
that's a great question i mean it has to
yeah i mean it's a lot but i figure at
least from like the cbd flower i've seen
it stuff it's not that key
that's true like there's like a little
rock in there still
wait what the f
oh wait i kind of
come on i'm wanna of curious here
press it
yeah
oh
oh
it's soft it's key very soft that is
kefi weird huh wow what should we do
with throw that in the middle
pretty wild right yeah that wow
that's it's just
it really does feel just like keith too
yeah that's just he [ __ ] weird we
just wanted something that's just keith
the people that smoke joints because not
everybody smokes panzer does edibles or
like you know what happens wow
cause i never thought we'd do joints
because it's got to be infused with hhc
always like
it's still weak but i mean that's the
reason yeah [ __ ] up yeah like these
you [ __ ] ate them on your [ __ ]
thing
like delicious
they will hit you oh 100 joke at all
yeah 100
um
but yeah i just wanted to make some
joints too because we didn't really know
if people would like him and holy [ __ ]
do they like them sorry
continue i'm so sorry we
did it it happens though i feel like
it's it's okay yes your dad
yes so i used to i used to bring extra
coke home you know and um i would always
do it off of plates and [ __ ] right it's
just the way to go i mean i didn't have
like a coke mirror any of that [ __ ] i
remember when i i gotten older i was
looking at like a snuff kit from the uk
you know that you could put in your
pocket because i really wanted one to
like put coke in and like just have
lines like pre-separated and chopped up
in that thing but i never bought one
it's one of my bigger regrets but um
like that would during my co-face it
would have been so cool it wasn't so
flat i was one of the double
dude imagine you play like a snuffy like
they had ones like made out of like like
crocodile like leather and [ __ ] like
super sick bro you can pull it out flat
be like yo
[ __ ] pull up flicks
go crazy back up
back the [ __ ] up get geek this [ __ ]
punch someone in the face [ __ ] start
raging go crazy [ __ ] techno music starts
playing somebody in the face just suck
whoever's pissing you off you know
i mean someone someone looks at you the
wrong way rock them but no so
i would do coke uh always off a plate
and i made the mistake of
you know
getting caught
with coke left on the plate that i kind
of forgotten to oh would you forget it i
would do it all you do it all would you
put on the plate i mean after a while
you you kind of get to that point where
like
you know i was trying to ration it
and i didn't i didn't like oh that's
different i thought you meant like no i
was trying to i it's i didn't bring home
like a large amount i was i was broke at
the time i literally uh i gave my buddy
like probably like 20 30 bucks for some
coke and he was like yo i'm eating one
more of these before i spark but [ __ ]
um
i gave him like 20 30 bucks and i was
like you know you know just get me what
you can he hooked me up fat but not
enough for me to go on a rampage but um
i was trying to really ration it doing
like a lot of the time a lot of time and
eventually i just kind of
got tired of it
you got tired of it
nerds crunching
it's going straight you're going crazy
martin should we're going to join what's
up hold on hold on where are we at marty
say about
three
nice say 2 40.
all right we're chilling today we stuck
about 45 minutes on soda
so we're hanging out today that's valid
that's a good pick this is okay wait
wait wait zombie duh yeah
cocaine zombie cures what time is it
though in real life
240. okay cool all right we're getting
close i have to go to that thing later
we got our uh call with these folks too
about 20. okay yeah well
we're getting close we're getting close
let's do this let's do this uh continue
you're dead um
so either way caught with the plate was
trying to ration right
my dad's the kind of guy where like
he will
confront you directly if
it's it's something something worse
right
um
like with weed he kind of got used to it
over time
but with coke
he was pissed
and he would do different things
depending on like this had happened more
than once right
more than once he'd found like different
drugs that i'd done like i mentioned
like remember when i went to rehab and i
had the acid in the freezer yeah [ __ ]
like that was really common
the coco he was pissed
yeah well this happened like probably a
good four or five times
you know
um
honestly which one did i make a video
about because i don't remember which
time this happened that i made a video
about i'm not sure i just saw the time
went oh i gotta ask
we got we gotta like pull up the video
or something we don't have time for that
do we
if you watch it but what's the time that
he caught you
he's caught me more than once what i'm
trying to say
okay well for example at one point he
caught me and he texted me and
i was out at the time because i i had a
job i worked a bunch of different jobs
and at this point i was working at a
grocery store um he texted me and i was
out and
i remember if i had just gotten off work
i remember i had worked that day and he
just told me to like
like come home and like talk to him
about it so i was just like
[ __ ] no dude i'm out of here um so
that was bad i wish i had to touch the
keefe it hit the table more than your
shirt though we're all good we
but um
so you texted me saying some crazy [ __ ]
like oh get your ass home like just
saying some nutty ass [ __ ] he would
always insult me in his text and should
be like oh you stupid [ __ ] bastard
like all this [ __ ] jesus christ yeah he
would say some crazy [ __ ] uh so
obviously i'm not coming home but also
at that point i'm like i'm sitting there
in my goddamn like grocery store uniform
you know like chilling i'd gotten off
work and i hadn't changed yet you know i
was out with my friends smoking and [ __ ]
so i was like bro what the like i have
like 50 dollars dude like
where the [ __ ] am i going you know so
i'm hitting up all my friends and i
stayed over at a buddy's house for like
a few days i was kind of couch surfing
for a few days sit over at my friend
cody's house one night oh you just never
answered the text and left no i just did
oh i just did it for like three four
days because i was like dude it was coke
bro like that's the thing when he would
find it most there's only like one time
he found it was like in a bag because i
never had enough to have like a large
bag of it it was always like a little
bit on a plate under like a dollar bill
that i put down you know that kind of
[ __ ] it was never like he'd find like my
[ __ ] giant stash of coke i didn't
have that kind of money back then man
it was like he'd find some lines or some
[ __ ] you know
so
hadoop for a few days
like i mentioned he's the kind of guy
who's mad for a day and he just kind of
forgets what happened i don't know if he
had short-term memory always so like
what
but
i went home like three days later and it
was just never spoken up again
oh see we just waited it out yeah i just
waited out the store i just waited out
the store yeah that's all i did like
that and that was typically the strategy
there was never a point where i couldn't
really wait it out you know um
i mean things kind of got bad with him
finding stuff when i'd gotten on
probation right before i went to rehab
it's part of the reason i went to rehab
because i didn't get on it go to rehab
my parents had figured that i wasn't
going to be able to stop and i was going
to like go to jail you know
yeah
i don't think that would have happened
but
whatever rehab made some good videos so
[ __ ] rehab made me money rehab was no
and most of that [ __ ] wasn't monetized
back then ah but still but no it got me
a lot of subs dude rehab is dub it's one
it's one of my favorite series i had a
lot of fun making that series because
like rehab is just such a crazy
experience i'll never experience
something that like just weird in my
life again like that [ __ ] was
interesting it was such a like
summer camp for tweakers
like
[Laughter]
can we open a [ __ ] help center that's
called summer camp for tweeters that
would be fire holy [ __ ] if you let
people know that you're here no that
would be genius i'll do it for free sake
summer camp for tweets that would be
genius that's incredible
i love it
we come up with a lot of bumper stickers
you've done you've dropped like seven
bumper sticker quotes
on these episodes but it was the one of
those oh we should drop some bumper
sticker merch oh bro you can't get
people pulled over true you're right
yeah so i thought about it before that's
why i haven't made sticker clings or
window clings or i feel that well
it's still like what's to say
you know he's got some wheat on him
well speaking of followers
what is this super twitter [ __ ] super
followers on twitter did you see his
thing ready no
excuse
me on twitter there's kind of like a sub
button on twitch where you could pay a
certain amount a month the person
decides and um you can see tweets are
exclusive to super followers it's kind
of [ __ ] worthless honestly and it
labels you as a super follower in the
replies and everything so it's kind of
like you know whatever you're flexing
whatever um
but i mean i don't know it's in its
current stage it's kind of pointless but
twitter i applied for it and they gave
it to me
and there's only like maybe i don't know
like a thousand or something accounts
that have it because like they follow
like kind of like when you get verified
you know the verified account follows
you
same thing with like this the uh super
follower account it follows you they
only follow like a thousand something
people
so like so people hey and they get to
see [ __ ] you can't post on normal
twitter not [ __ ] you can't post but just
you choose to post on that side it's not
like there's different rules for it or
anything
um
his current stage is kind of weird i
don't know i only have like 140 150
super followers so not like a crazy
amount but a good amount i made my
dollar amount the lowest possible the
lowest you can go is three dollars a
month
so i picked that because i was like well
i just tweet stupid [ __ ] really i don't
have that that's right the twitter's
getting into twitch essentially yeah but
the thing is i don't know how the
payment system works because they
haven't paid me yet so
it's a big part of it twitter's just
making you think you're getting paid out
yeah i mean i think they only owe me
like a couple hundred bucks
but still whatever yeah payments it's
good though to get paid by these
platforms like yeah it does and when you
get like that first check from a
platform it's like oh i've been doing
this for free for a minute and like damn
you know
uh instagram offered me make money on
your reels today deleted me two hours
later that's so [ __ ]
i got deleted again on [ __ ] instagram
guys
so stupid you getting it back though
hopefully right we'll see we'll see i
hope so
uh i'm praying for you we'll see but i
decided it was funny crossing my fingers
so super followers on twitter is
essentially the twitch version
pretty much yeah it's the twitter
version of the twitch sub
there it is
i didn't even know that existed i just
saw i don't know i didn't know for a
while either until i saw i could apply
for it i'm like what the [ __ ] is this
but
it's cool i guess [ __ ] twitter's
crazy now
so is it gonna change now that
[ __ ] bought it i don't know bro
i mean elon he isn't in control of it
yet i don't think
but when he gets in control of it i
don't know we could see some interesting
[ __ ] that'd be cool they're like yo you
can just run giveaways like for weed
stuff yeah twitter i mean twitter's
pretty like loose which is pretty chill
i don't i haven't been suspended ever on
twitter before honestly no twitter
yeah twitter's chill
you can do pretty much anything on there
it's [ __ ] up they're the only one
that's like no guys do what you want
everybody's like yeah yeah all the other
people all the other platforms are so
like so strict and they have so many
petty rules like if it's legal where
you're doing it you should be able to do
it you know
i don't know it's weird but we'll see
um
so my next question
it is beginning of may
what are your plans for the rest of this
year 2022 getting the podcast going i
want to drop some glass
you're working on the glass to like have
sets and lines of goblin glass right
yeah yeah i want to put out some really
dope [ __ ] i want some really really cool
designs trying to make them affordable
and like source them still
so
definitely a work in progress but like
this year i want to have like
a piece at least like a prototype in my
hand by the end of the year you know oh
you can have that soon yeah yeah
um other than that just podcasts and
banging out more videos man
so stay consistent podcast you're gonna
have them on
on youtube you're going to drop them
somewhere else i'm going to drop them on
youtube i want to start doing spotify as
well um you should and those are
probably the two platforms i'm going to
focus on for it at least for now there's
a bunch that we
we do i don't know it's like a one you
can upload to all right yeah
that's what you should do and to post on
spotify you need to get a distribution
deal right
no i don't know don't you have to like
sign up for one of those sites or
something yeah yeah i'll let you know
what you need to do okay cool yeah i'm
not sure
but yeah dude i'm [ __ ] excited for
that thank you i appreciate it so glass
podcasts
chilling grinding chilling [ __ ]
making more videos
that's the plan
all right all right so where can
everybody find everything you do in case
this is the first time you've ever seen
him before you should look up goblin on
youtube or
goblin420.com it's got all my links at
the top left goblin 20.com yep okay
either one of those instagram is still
deleted
um no i have a my current instagram
gbln420 okay which is active still
chilling uh my original one got deleted
right before i hit 100k which really
sucked it's always the same sorry i'm
almost at 50k right now so
i need to get there um i'm on twitter
snapchat all that
all on my website
all right so basically the goblin
420.com goblin 420.com or lookup goblin
on youtube i got all my links on either
and then work you get all your merch
same thing that
okay it's the the one stop shop what's
selling the most right now
oh
right now um
i mean the only gas [ __ ] has been going
hard for like a year dude that [ __ ] is
always on top but the of the acid merch
the lsd design i'm actually working on a
new one because that one is like
consistently alongside the water bottles
i just put out
like yeah i just put out some water
bottles uh what do they have on it
the the acid design like from my shirt
oh it's on the water bottle yeah it's on
the water bottle and it the way it comes
out it looks really dope actually we put
like a little border on it it looks it
looks sick but um
that shit's telling we're working on a
new merch shop right now
now that the the grinders are out of the
way i can kind of focus on that so good
[ __ ] [ __ ] yeah i'm dropping grinders
this week [ __ ] yeah dude nice i gotta
re-up on it what's the colorway on them
i'll show you there's
all red all gold like i've done and then
black green black gray has been going
hard dude dude i got so many yeah most
i've ever gotten i want some stallback
tables how many you got a couple hundred
man oh [ __ ] it takes so long to make
those yeah i know bro it takes [ __ ]
forever dude
it just makes me happy knowing it's like
all right it's pretty good yeah yeah no
it's burning great it just took a while
look at that that's that's a white
background it took a while to come out
because i was like we gotta make sure
it's like
it's at least it goes to pre-roll this
door
yep you know cause it's like it's cbd
flower it's only so much you can really
do yeah a hundred percent the [ __ ] you
want me to do here 100 but it has htc
units that's why it's like it's nice i
like this [ __ ] dude um
all right so the goblin 420
yes sir
let's go i'm hot it is [ __ ] cloudy
maybe because i haven't made anything
we're just eating this yeah i'm running
on an empty stomach i didn't even eat
dinner yesterday
[ __ ] i'm a hungry dude
yesterday never mind i was thinking what
the [ __ ] can i do we're getting food oh
i hate chili beans like i said they look
good
it was not that great
but i'm hungry right now yeah i'm
[ __ ] starving all right sick so
anything any other plans chilling
grinding it out going on no jumpers
seeming that's going to be fun
uh may 25th is when i go filming oh this
month yeah bro
you'll be back yeah i'll be back in l.a
soon we'll kick it [ __ ] yeah dude yeah
so this week we're gonna film some stuff
we may or may not take some mushrooms
yeah we'll have some fun i got my camera
with me so we can figure out what we're
gonna do this this uh this week because
you're here all week yep ah all right
well my high ass in two hours three
hours i get to go announce at the nhl
playoff game in downtown l.a you're
telling me about that that's [ __ ]
sick that's gonna be all [ __ ] up all
these animals
i know it sounds fake but it's true
shout out to ratchaton matchy man
so we're doing espn latin again i don't
speak spanish see you there
uh so after that i'll [ __ ] hit you up
maybe we'll call it
yeah i'm down i'm down hit me up
after i'm done announcing the hockey
game
in english on the spanish channel
and they translate for me but susan esp
on the espn i saw your friend tom as
high as [ __ ] on there
uh another water boy reference okay
thank you man oh yeah thank you for
having me thanks for being here dude
this felt like it was seconds yeah this
one did not feel like we went like like
we were i think it's because we did it
so early in the day maybe i felt like
this was fast yeah we just how how long
is this about three hours yeah a little
over it's usually like 1am at this point
that's why yeah
we got the whole
yeah like it makes me feel like
okay no this is sick yeah i'm pumped i'm
glad i'm glad we got this stone this
early
i like that i like it
it's a good call i'm glad we got this
stone this early it's a good bumper
sticker too right on the way out that's
another one i like that [ __ ] yeah dude
gotta do what i gotta do all right what
are we gonna do send lewds
yes sir oh that's gonna be so sad lose
a chick with your shirt oh
wait let's just say coming soon goblin
for twenty dollars a good one i like it
i'll make it happen
all right i've already got anything else
oh [ __ ] i don't know this is [ __ ]
ridiculous i'm glued dude i don't know
bro
these are my favorite i don't know these
are like
every time these always smack these
always hit hard yeah these are fun makes
you good episodes i can't wait to we're
in the live chat i'm going
sorry guys for the soda talk
for 20 minutes we just got high and
talked about soda
first i mean good it was great i wanted
to know dr pepper is just like what
how did we get that shirt
how did you get here from this like what
the [ __ ] my notes don't say oh pop
it's not the right word
that's the right word it's not the right
word
but i don't care let's do what you're
gonna do i just it's funny um
well thank you for being here appreciate
you martial
i'm glad i stood up for my usage of the
turn oh
i'm already with you guys confident man
marty's with you he just says i'll have
a
what drinks soft fountain drinks do you
have
fountain drinks or soft drinks i'll just
have a beverage i'm gonna start saying
beverage or soft drink yeah
there we go ball of [ __ ]
so now everybody knows marty's like one
of the guys that says pop
i didn't know that toy i was today
um the zombies usual podcast will no
longer be playing anymore this is it
marty's gone yeah he's out
right he's a party
party show's gonna be just me by myself
in my closet
[ __ ] with the grow light just like
2015
speaking with bob barker microphone so
i'm about to be on my [ __ ]
it's like i do have a girl name i do
have bob marker to be in my living room
put the blanket over with a little like
crazy yo you don't want me ratcheting
ratchet man yeah this [ __ ] real
quick my homie on sub l ratchatone on on
twitch
this full told me i want to do a
subathon like so every time someone
subscribes i said he posted this the
other day
how long did he stay on for it was 25
minutes for every sub
dumb
right i told him 25 minutes for every
sub make it bro i could drop 150 and
ruin his life that's what i did i
dropped 150 and i added like 10 hours
and then a little bit later i added five
more and a little bit later added five
more and then right when he was 31
minutes away last night i dropped 10 on
it
so he did the whole
thing wow he slept in the chair all
night on me
he did so much 72. wow
that's insane
how'd he do that [ __ ] he just sat there
and just did stuff i think the longest
stream i've ever done was like 12 hours
but it was great because i'm like yo
that's too much time and then he started
trying to lower it at the end and go no
he's still 25.
he [ __ ] up so it was great he was 31
minutes away he got back with his food
he's like i'm so glad [ __ ] yeah
and somebody else did 10-2 so he's still
on
[ __ ] yeah we gotta go to the game in a
minute so you're gonna be done
we start live streaming from this phone
sorry what is your twitch before we get
out of here gbln420 gbl same as my
instagram and when do you get on
um
it's random huh yeah i really don't
schedule anything so if you [ __ ] with
twitch go watch this turn my
notifications on don't miss [ __ ] or
follow me on twitter i always tweet when
i'm live go watch this full be a fool on
gta and do stupid things and do funny
stuff that's what twitch is for
which is fun
which is a fun time it's about my pc i
told you yes dude you're gonna have fun
on twitch bro twitch is a fun time i'm
joining you very soon it's fun yes dude
hop on that [ __ ] we'll [ __ ] go cook
meth or whatever you know
it'll be fine it's just gta in gta not
real life just grand theft auto i mean i
would in real life do some of that oh
hell no i cook my ass dude omar makes
sells meth and cooks tacos he has a taco
shop in gta role play oh that's fire
he's an immigrant in his [ __ ] thing
like bro you didn't go that far
one generation back [ __ ]
you went 20 years before you were born
that's all you did
[ __ ]
that's so fire um
all right so everybody go follow this
[ __ ] on twitch and go have fun
thank you all right
go have fun go watch twitch yes sir i
think it's everything the goblin 420 uh
calm for everything else
uh all right thank you man thank you for
being here marty we're done we're out of
here
that's all the questions it's everything
hell yeah let's get it thank you for
having me appreciate you you're
officially the guest that's been back
the most [ __ ] yeah official
official we gotta get in there we gotta
get a guest of the year award made for
him yeah you got it just a little let's
do it a little like something like that
but like super tight like dog sick you
know what i'm saying dude let's do like
a like a you should do like an award
ceremony like let your viewers vote when
you walk in
it's just gonna be a red carpet carpet
in the hallway yeah as you walk
yeah
some really sick lights
invite like some hall of fame guests all
at the same time yeah that'd be intense
we have og give you your [ __ ] yeah
basically have all your friends just you
know come back we'll all smoke it up and
give me a
what trophy all the whole things they're
all my friends right he's [ __ ] right
yeah
but it's i agree
yeah i would be sick
of people vote on it [ __ ] that would be
though oh
that's we're doing the dope as usual
podcast on instagram that shit's coming
very soon we should do that yeah it's
happening i already envisioned all as
soon as you said that okay [ __ ] yeah all
right marty's on graphic designer
beautiful here we go all right so before
we leave the main thing we want to take
away from this episode
it's the goblin 420.com
goblin 420 check out some [ __ ]
merchants see every single thing you can
get with content creators that's all we
get we can't advertise we can't get
commercials
so go be cool they hate us out there
check some [ __ ] out they're playing
they're player-hating that's true that's
true if you don't buy [ __ ] just watch
some [ __ ] of course it's free as hell go
to my videos and click on all the ads
oh you're monetized he's monetized on
youtube guys my second channel go to my
second channel go to my second channel
what is the second channel
goblin 420 goblin 420 yes regular
channel is goblin yep
they'll find me either way all right you
guys will find it but support content
creators because they're [ __ ]
making you laugh and entertain you for
[ __ ] free
remember that
yes sir thank you man thank you for
being here yup thank you for having me
all right are you ready yes you're ready
all right guys this has been the dope's
usual podcast all right i was at dot com
[ __ ] this has been the dope usual
podcast
from goblin marty and i
have a dope ass day thank you all and
let's go start our day it's like the
[ __ ] start of it it's [ __ ] time
let's do it yo those sharks those sharks
got me hungry
[Music]